oh yeah
is
is
one more thing
okay
thank you
welcome ladies
how are you
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have a lot of relatives
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
people will talk they see us together
again
it's very good morning
[Music]
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before we have the jury
of course we do that's fine
all right are we ready for the jury
thank you
all right
be seated
all right next question
good morning miss heard good morning
your relationship with mr depp began in
october of 2011 right that's correct and
you previously testified multiple times
under oath
that the first year of your relationship
with mr depp was the best of times right
mister
that is correct you testified that as
far as you could tell mr depp was sober
that first year
that is correct that's what i used to
believe
and that the first year was quote magic
yes i always uh estimated it was about a
year
but now you've told this jury
that mr depp was being violent with you
throughout 2012. haven't you misheard
no he took a break in the middle of 2012
when he was sober
you told them
that he was hitting you in 2012 though
is that right he was hitting me in 2012.
he just took a break in the middle
he was smashing things around you right
he did
and you told them that mr deb was in and
out of sobriety in 2012
that is correct
you told this jury that quote in 2012 i
was in the beginning stages of this just
learning these patterns i was learning
that drinking kind of correlated with
the violence end quote is that right
that is correct
so it was during these cycles of
violence in 2012 that you gave mr dap a
knife as a gift
i gave him a knife um
i think for a birthday present early in
our relationship i believe it was around
2012 but i'm not certain
we've seen a picture of that knife but i
think we should bring out the real thing
master deputy
halusa master deputy sheriff luther may
please have you
show the knife
to ms heard
yes that's it
that's the knife you gave to the man who
was hitting you right mister
i wasn't worried he was gonna stab me
with it when i gave it to him that's for
certain but you gave it to him while he
was abusing you allegedly i gave it to
him that year
master deputy sheriff lusa will you
please show the knife to the jury
thank you
this is the knife you gave to the man
who would get drunk and violent with you
right
this is the same knife that i gave him
as a present in 2012 yes
now miss heard i'm going to need to talk
to you about what happened in australia
in march of 2015.
you've testified that at some point
during the incident you described you
witnessed mr depp bashing the phone
against a wall right that is correct you
testified that the phone was breaking
into pieces
i was watching it disappear now mr depp
smashed it i think your word was
smithereens
yes that is correct
and according to your testimony this was
a wall-mounted phone in the bar area
that is correct
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
one eight two zero
i miss i believe this has already been
admitted into evidence if we could have
it published
thank you
you saw this photo during your direct
examination right
that is correct and you testified that
the wall-mounted phone that you saw mr
depp's smash is on the wall on the left
that's correct so if you were looking at
this picture the wall the wall mounted
phone would have been behind you on the
left-hand side of your shoulder but it's
not depicted depicted in this photo
correct whoever took this photo standing
right in front of where that um mountain
phone was
it's convenient
um the pieces of the phone mr dap smash
aren't in this picture either right
you don't see it because it's whoever
took this photo standing in front of
that
whoever took this photo it's mr ben king
correct
that's what i believe yeah mr king
testified under oath in this trial right
that is correct and he testified that
there was no wall-mounted phone smashed
to smithereens that he had to replace
correct
i didn't hear him testify to that no
he did
the council elicited it
i disagree with that representation
you also saw this picture
actually can we please bring that
defendant's exhibit 1821
which is also admitted
into evidence
[Music]
you also saw this picture during your
direct examination correct that is
correct and so this is the bar area to
the right of the wall mounted phone you
just described
if you were facing in that direction if
you're facing this direction it will be
behind you
this phone on the counter isn't the
phone that got smashed to smithereens is
it
no they brought that out um during my
testimony in the uk as well and i said
this in the uk trial as well but that is
not the phone
obviously because that one's not smashed
and it's not wall mounted yeah so there
are two phones in the bar area
there there was a wall mounted phone i
don't know if it was decorative or what
but it was white like it looked antique
large and antique
and and one the large and antique one
that's not depicted in any photograph
including ones you took
is the one that mr depp damaged correct
that is correct i only took pictures of
the mirrors
so there's no picture of that damaged
phone i didn't take a picture of it no
okay so back to the phone smashing you
watched mr dap smash the phone right
that's correct i watched it and you
testified that you were quote watching
the phone every single time he pulled
his hand back end quote that's correct
and according to you this is when mr
dupp lost the tip of his finger right it
is my best guess i didn't notice his
finger
come off obviously i was um watching him
smash the phone and watching the pieces
break while he was doing it well it's
not your best guess ms heard that is my
best guess okay let's go back to
my questions
you submitted a declaration under the
penalty of perjury in this case do you
remember that that is correct okay let's
look at that declaration
yes ma'am
thank you
if we could direct your attention
misheard to the
page 14 of the declaration
is that your signature
yes it is and your signature appears
right under the statement quote i
declare under penalty of perjury under
the laws of the state of virginia that
the foregoing is true and correct
that is correct
and this is dated april 10 2019
correct now let's look at paragraph 16
which is on page five
specifically line ten
quote
you write testify under oath
while he was smashing the phone johnny
severely injured his finger cutting off
the top of it end quote did i read that
correctly yes that's correct
you testified in this courtroom that
after mr dev smashed the phone he held
you down on the countertop by the neck
do you remember that
i'm not quite sure the exact sequence of
things but yes both of those things
happened
we'll get to the sequence and this is
when mr depp supposedly assaulted you
with a bottle right
on the countertop he assaulted me so mr
depp was able to get you on the counter
right
he held me down by my neck and hold you
down by your neck
that is correct
and he grabbed a bottle
according to you
while holding you down by the neck
correct i'm sorry can you clarify what
you're asking me
while mr depp is holding you by the neck
against the countertop he grabs the
bottle that's your testimony no those
two things didn't happen at the exact
same time no
while he so he's holding the bottle is
that your testimony while holding you
down by the neck sorry what was your
question
your testimony is misheard that either
he has the bottle before or after he's
holding you by the neck on the counter
is that your testimony he held me by the
neck on the counter
where's the bottle
that he's at what point
while holding you down by your neck
when he was assaulting me with the
bottle it was in his hand
was it in his hand before or after he
holds you down by your neck
i was being held down
while he assaulted me with the bottle
when he puts you on the counter does he
have the bottle in his hand yes or no
as i have always said i don't remember
exactly what happened first i don't
remember the sequence i just remember
being aware that i was being assaulted
by a bottle while i was on the
countertop so he penetrates you with
this bottle
but you don't know how he got the bottle
right that is correct
and he did that right after he lost the
tip of his right middle finger again i
don't remember the exact sequence of
those events we'll get to the sequence
and while he was on 8 to 10 mdma peel
pills right
let's yes about the sequence
this is the sequence of events you
testify to in this courtroom
that he smashed the phone to smithereens
and then assaulted you
lost the tip of his finger and then
assaulted you with a bottle
yes that's the sequence of events that
you testify to and then
to be clear you're putting it in order
when you say words like then
i have never claimed that i can remember
the exact sequence of these things this
was a multi-day assault that took place
over three horrible days that's her
worst thing
we're not talking it's heard that's not
my question my question isn't about the
three-day assault allegedly that
occurred i'm just talking about the
sexual assault that you now allege
occurred
okay correct let's talk about the
sequence
so you testified
actually
yeah i know i just realized that
we gave it to you yesterday
court transcript
yes
[Music]
mister do you have a copy of day 16 in
front of you
uh day 16 yes my deposition yes no of
the court transcript from this trial
yes i i didn't realize that this yeah
let's look at the transcript
so you testified on page i'm getting
there
four five zero six
all right okay
the reason that we need to go through
this ms hurt is because we understand
that these are very serious allegations
that you're making right
it was horrible what happened to me yes
okay so let's go through them
page four five zero six line two through
three
i sit here now
i apologize
you testified on page four five zero six
this all started when mr depp took eight
or 10 pills of mdma right
that is correct
then directing your attention to page
4518
line 19.
you talk about mr dev smashing a
wall-mounted phone
correct that is correct
then on page 4519
at line three
you testified that while mr depp is
smashing the phone he is screaming quote
i [ __ ] hate you end quote right
yes he he was screaming that among other
things
and further down on page 4519 same page
lines 12 through 19
you talk about how you watched mr deaf
smash the phone to smithereens
right
that is correct
then
continuing on on same page four five one
nine line twenty you say something
really important
quote at some point he's on top of me
no phone but screaming the same thing
end quote right i just remember the
sound yes
but you remember and you testified to
this jury
that he didn't have the phone in his
hand anymore when he was assaulting me
with the bottle he had the bottle in his
hand when he was punching the wall with
the phone he had the phone in his hand
when he was punching the wall next to my
head he had me by the throat
he did a lot of things at night
so you're acknowledging by this sequence
not my words your words misheard that
you testified to this jury and mr depp
smashed the phone to smithereens before
he assaulted you
that's the way that's the sequencing in
which you testified correct
i have never testified to a sequence
keep talking about that sequence then on
page four five two one
starting at line three
you testify to being bent over backwards
on the bar
right
okay
directing your attention ms heard to
page four five two one starting at line
three
you testify to being bent over backwards
on the bar right
that is correct
and then feeling pressure on your pubic
bone like mr depp was punching you
yes
that's what i thought
and then further down on page four five
two one
and on to four five two two
you testified that you were concerned mr
depp was using a broken bottle on you
yes that was my fear
okay that's what i remember feeling
let's heard i'm going to show you
defendants exhibit 1816.
which has already been admitted
yes yeah thank you you saw this picture
during your direct examination right i
did
and you testified that this is a picture
of the bottles that were next to mr depp
on a desk when you found him drinking in
the morning right that's correct
and this was the morning after mr deb
had allegedly sexually assaulted you
right it was the morning after he did
assault me yes and if i understood your
testimony correctly you testified that
this is the maker's mark bottle that mr
dapp sexually assaulted you with
i was never sure
it was but it was definitely that shape
felt like that shape
but you testified in this courtroom that
you had not seen this bottle until ben
king provided these photographs correct
not in the course of the trial i hadn't
seen the photograph
you claim you had serious injuries after
this alleged incident right misheard
depends on what you would call serious
for me um you know having a sore jaw and
some bruises uh at the time of my
relationship wasn't that serious
let's testify let's focus on the
testimony that you gave about the
injuries
mr depp as you testified yesterday wears
rings on every finger right
sometimes i mean often and certainly in
the later part of our relationship that
was more normal than not but if he's
filming or something like that of course
he's not going to have his own jewelry
on your testimony
in this trial was
quote i don't know if i've ever known
johnny not to wear rings
correct
you need to put your microphone on miss
thank you objection you're on
improper impeachment there she's going
to ask her question then she has to show
where that was and then rule the
objection going thank you
your testimony yesterday was quote i
don't know if i've ever known johnny not
to wear rings right that's heard that's
what i testified to yes okay and he was
wearing rings on every finger in
australia correct
not all the time not literally every
single ring every single day but he
often wears drinks
not often ms heard your words are i've
never known johnny not to wear rings on
every finger
that is what i testified too okay
and you testified that you bled as a
result of this sexual assault correct
that is correct
and you testified that your forearms
were cut
my forearms and my feet and your feet
were sliced up
that's correct and you testified you had
a bruise across your jaw
that is correct
and there is not a single medical record
reflecting treatment for any of those
injuries is they're misheard
i didn't seek treatment
and the day after you sustained all
these injuries dr david kipper came to
the house in australia right
well he came the third day
along with security
the day after you sustained these
injuries as dr david kipper came along
with nurse debbie lloyd correct well
that fight went into the morning like
early hour morning so technically that
last day
dr david kipper is mr depp's or was mr
death's uh physician right
i believe he still is
but he was at the time yes that's
correct and he was also your physician
he also saw me
no not saw you he was your physician
correct mister uh johnny was the client
but he also treated me
all right let's please pull up do you
remember giving testimony in this case
in a deposition misheard yes i do i've
given a couple
if we could please
pull up the deposition transcript day
two
um at 589 lines six through eight
yes thank you
thank you
um your honor
we're going to play miss hurd's
deposition for the jury
uh lines day two page 540 lines six
through nine
if we have permission to publish it
excuse me i'm sorry day two page 589
line six through eight all right could
you just give us a minute to get of
course 589
i'm sorry what were the lines again page
589 lines six through eight
did you say 540 or 580
589
lines 6 through 8. all right thank you
thank you
i have no objection here
and he was your doctor at this point
right yes he was
debbie lloyd also came to the house that
day
yes she came with kipper
miss lloyd is a nurse correct that is
correct
malcolm connolly also came to the house
that day
yes that's correct mr connolly is one of
the security guards correct that is
correct
you had known mr connolly for years at
that point
yes that's correct
you flew back to los angeles the next
day with ben king is that right
i can't be certain if it was uh the next
day or the day after but somewhere
around there yes
and the day you arrived back in los
angeles you saw travis mcgivern correct
i don't recall seeing travis snow you
don't recall mr mcgivern picking you up
from the airport with ben king i don't
remember that no
okay
and the same day you also saw your own
nurse aaron brown fellate that day
correct the day you arrived in los
angeles i don't recall if i saw her that
day
you saw miss pilate's testimony in this
case by a video deposition correct that
is correct and you heard her testify
that she saw you the day you arrived
back from australia on march 9th 2015. i
believe she testified that she
came to dinner
where i was with friends yeah i believe
that so she saw you that day
i believe that evening i saw her at
dinner okay
and then you saw aaron baranthaladi
again the next day for a private meeting
didn't you
i i'm not sure if that if that's what
she testified to i'd have to just see
the records to know you heard her
testify according to her notes she met
with you privately on march 10 2015. she
met with me at some point upon my
arrival but i don't remember the duct
date
and when you were in australia is heard
you didn't take any pictures of the
injuries you claimed to have sustained
right i did not take any pictures no but
you did take two pictures
of the mirrors i took two pictures of
the bathroom mirrors that um
was the master bathroom where i was
let's please pull up defendants exhibit
374 which is already in evidence
you took this picture right mister
yes that's correct and this is a mirror
in the bathroom in australia that's
correct
and this black paint on the mirror is
from mr depp that is correct he wrote on
the mirror in black paint after his
finger was cut off right
uh yes uh i only know that because there
was blood in his wall of paint
so you took this picture after mr deb
had injured his fingers correct this was
while i was packing when i was leaving
that's the only photo
that's
what's the question i'm sorry
you took this picture after mr dapp had
injured his finger that's correct
and you took this picture after you had
allegedly been assaulted by mr depp yes
that's correct
yeah you didn't capture yourself in the
mirror did you
i don't
see myself in the mirror no okay
let's please pull up defendants exhibit
375.
you took this picture as well right miss
heard that's correct and this is from
one of the bathroom mirrors in australia
that's correct this is also a picture
taken after mr depp had injured his
finger
that's correct
and this is also a picture taken after
you had allegedly been assaulted by mr
depp
that's correct
you didn't capture yourself in the
mirror in this picture either did you i
do not see myself in the mirror in that
picture
is that because you didn't have any
visible injuries on you
because i was taking a picture of the
writing
let's talk about the writing on this
mirror
so the writing and black paint is from
mr depp correct
it's all from mr duck
and it's your testimony under oath that
you did not write the red text that says
quote call carly simon she said it
better babe
that's correct
because if you did write that it means
that your husband was walking around the
house bleeding from his amputated finger
and you're writing snarky messages to
him on a mirror right
i don't know what your question to me is
i'm sorry
let's please take a look at defense
exhibit one eight three zero
i believe this
this picture is also admitted into
evidence
that's correct this is a picture of the
same mirror right
that's correct but you didn't take this
picture
no i did not this is the one that ben
king took
and i don't see him in the mirror either
[Music]
he's i don't believe he claimed he had
injuries though is that right
i did not hear ben king talk about his
injuries no okay
so you would agree mr that the black
text on the mirror says quote
she loves naked photos of herself
so modern
so hot
i had not read that yet i mean before
but yeah that's what it says
but you were taking pictures of the text
but you had not read that before i
haven't seen this it didn't make sense
to me at the time when i read it in
person okay again mr dupp wrote that
i don't know who else would have
so miss her just to be clear it's your
testimony that mr depp also wrote the
message in red about carly simon saying
it better right that's correct you know
carly simon saying the song you're so
vain right i was told that
so it's your testimony that mr depp was
writing messages to himself in the
mirror back and forth
the best i can describe it is it looked
like
a crazy conversation it was on the walls
within slam shades it was on cushions
it's your testimony the crazy
conversation was with himself that's
what it looked like
from the bloody messages i found and you
would agree with me that in this
photograph the red text has been smudged
with black paint
right
yes okay
let's please pull up if we can
defendants exhibit three five excuse me
three seven five again
box smudge isn't in this picture that
you took right that's correct
so mr dutt must have not liked his own
message to himself
i'm not quite sure what was happening
when ben took that the his photograph no
okay
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
343 which is already in evidence and
play the portion
from
1 57 21 through 1 58 54. it's recording
your honor
it's just to get out of a bad situation
while it's happening before it gets
worse
in australia when we had the big fight
where i lost the tip of my finger
at least
five bathrooms and two bedrooms i went
to
two two
two boy talking to me
to escape the fight you don't escape the
fight you escape the solution you escape
the solution you escape figuring it out
we cannot work it out if you run away to
the bathroom every time listen to me
listen to me
a boxer can't go 12 rounds without a
[ __ ] minute break i'm not not giving
you a minute break you do it at minute
three at the beginning of an argument no
there are rounds man and when it gets
too [ __ ] hairy
the ref splits them apart or whatever
but i'm all i'm saying is
you you can't have a solution if
the argument just keeps mounting and
mounting and mounting and mounting i
[ __ ] go to the into the bathroom and
sit on the floor bam bam bam here you
come
i come out
fight fight fight crazy escalated i go i
split again i go to another [ __ ]
bathroom or a bedroom or something knock
knock knock bang bang bang
you kept coming to get me
every
this is what really happened in
australia isn't it misheard
uh i did knock on a bathroom door on the
first night
not a bathroom door five bathroom doors
and two bedrooms uh is not an accurate
historian of what happened it's heard uh
this period of time i'll guarantee it's
heard that's not my question five
bathroom doors two bedrooms that's what
you knocked on
that's what actually happened in
australia isn't it misheard i was there
i remember it i knocked on one bathroom
door i came on the first night after he
decided to take the
bag of mdma and i heard to check this
i'm going to move to strike everything
after i knocked on one back door she's
answering the question
not quite so i will sustain the
objection just answer the question okay
the recording we just listened to that's
exactly what happened in australia
mr depp lost the tip of his finger after
you threw a bottle at him isn't that
right
that is incorrect
you're the one who assaulted someone
with a bottle in australia isn't that
right ms hurd i didn't assault johnny in
australia i didn't assault johnny ever i
couldn't and then after he was injured
he had to hide from you right that is
five bathrooms two bedrooms that is
incorrect
and you would pursue him
that is incorrect because he was
avoiding talking to you
right
he did that first night and he was
avoiding he talked to him about the
drugs and he was avoiding working it out
no he was uh avoiding
agreeing to not fight about the drugs
you weren't scared of him at all were
you
i have a uh
a mixed relationship with johnny and one
in which i'm scared
one in which i love him very much i'm
not talking about your mixed
relationship
that night in australia
after you cut off his finger with a
bottle you weren't scared of him at all
were you
this is a man who tried
to kill me of course it's scary he's
also my husband
sir i'm going to show you what's been
marked as defendant's exhibit three
seven one
do not believe these have been admitted
into evidence
no i don't okay
i don't have them
if we can scroll down please
no
mr huff if you don't have your
microphone on i cannot hear you
you still don't have it on
redact oh
i need to take a look at the unredacted
from your honor just bear with me all
right i'm not admitting that into
evidence yet i would like to just talk
to the witness about it if i could thank
you your honor
ms heard i'm going to show you what's
been marked as defendants exhibit 371 do
you recognize these text messages
between you and uh dr cowan
i don't recognize these no
who's dr cowan he was um my therapist
that uh was recommended to me from dr
kipper uh he and dr kemper worked
together
he was your therapist at the time
correct
that's correct
and you had been seen him for almost a
year in march of 2015
my guess would be about six months
at that point
your text messages aren't great correct
you're i'm going
i'm going to ask that she show her the
unredacted so that she can see the text
exchange back and forth because she
wants to talk about movies
later
thank you pull it up
[Music]
seeing these unredacted messages just
this refresher recollection that these
are indeed communications between you
and dr cowan
yes that's correct okay
doctor your text messages aren't great
correct
yes that's correct and dr collins are in
blue
that is correct okay do you see the text
message at the bottom of the page from
march 8th
2015 at 8 29 pm
yes that's correct march 8th is the day
that you were allegedly sexually
assaulted by mr depp in australia
correct that is correct so on march 8th
2015 you were in australia
that is correct and mr dutt's finger had
just been cut off right that is correct
and you write to dr cowen quote
i feel so lost
i can't talk
i don't know if i'll ever be able to
change
end quote
did i read that correctly that's correct
you weren't able to change where you
misheard
i very much wanted to leave the
relationship i was in but i didn't
have the power i didn't feel i had the
power to leave i knew i was in a very
toxic relationship with johnny and i
knew i needed to change that i knew it
was at this point
horrible for me
and i talked to my therapist often about
that exhibit
defendant's exhibit 371 as redacted with
just miss heard's messages all right
your order i object because she has left
out the next two lines from miss heard
that clarify even further and i also
think mr collins
so you're on earth i'm going to move to
admit defendants exhibit 371 as redacted
all right 371 and evidence as
redacted over objection
yes ma'am if you can publish that to the
jury thank you
so you write miss heard to dr cowan i
feel so lost i can't talk i don't know
if i'll ever be able to change
right
and i said i clearly can't figure this
out meaning the relationship
you didn't say that i did
not the relationship
your text messages clearly i can't
figure this out i feel so lost right now
what i was saying to him no no no no i
can't miss her
that's not my question
the text
just the text that's what you were
saying what you texted
clearly i can't figure this out i feel
so lost right now
that's that's what i was saying okay
thank you
that's where do you continue you're
under just for clarification so those
two next lines did come in they are in
the red okay good all right thank you
mr do you contend that there's another
incident of abuse in march of 2015 after
you and mr depp returned from australia
is that correct
that's correct
and this is incident took place on march
23 2015 that's correct and this
supposedly occurred in the penthouse at
the eastern columbia building
that's correct
you had found text messages between mr
depp and another woman right
that is correct so you confronted him
about cheating on you
that's correct
and this was about two weeks after you
had returned from australia
that's correct so this is shortly after
mr deb supposedly sexually assaulted you
with a bottle right
it was two weeks after he assaulted me
yes and you decided to confront him
about cheating on you
um i i didn't decide to i
i i wanted to
mr duff's finger was freshly injured at
this point right he had a cast on it the
top of his right finger had been cut off
two weeks prior
that is correct and he had a pin in his
finger true
i don't recall when the pen was placed
a skin graft
i'm not quite sure he had several
different procedures and they were kind
of spread out over a period of time so i
don't remember what happened in one of
those exactly procedures was to treat
the mrsa that got on his finger too
right at some point i knew he had an
infection
and his right hand was in a bandage
right it was casted
so it's your testimony that mr depp was
able to attack both you and your sister
with his hand in that state right that
is correct he had a hard plaster cast on
it
debbie lloyd was present in the
penthouses when mr depp supposedly
attacked you isn't that correct
that's correct in fact you claim that mr
depp threw a red bull can at miss lloyd
that evening
yes that's correct and you put in a
sworn statement to that effect in the uk
case right that is correct
but that's not true is it
that's what happened
you know what a deposition is right
misheard i've had several yes yeah so
you know it's when someone provides
testimony under oath that is correct
you're aware that miss lloyd was deposed
in connection with this case correct
that's true
and miss lloyd's deposition testimony
was played earlier in this trial right
i'm getting jack turner may we approach
all right
so in a deposition miss heard
you know it's when someone provides
testimony under oath right that's
correct you're aware that miss lloyd was
deposed in connection with this case
that's correct and miss lloyd's
deposition testimony was played earlier
in this trial
yes so you heard ms lloyd testify
under oath that mr depp never threw a
can of red bull at her
i can't remember if she didn't run if
she didn't recall that or if she said it
didn't happen i don't remember
i vaguely since she didn't recall
anything
so it's your testimony that miss lloyd
would forget that mr depp a very famous
patient of hers threw a can of red bull
that nearly missed her according to your
version of events
to be fair i just don't remember if she
said when she testified that she didn't
recall that incident or if it didn't
happen i don't remember what she
testified to but i have a vague sense
she didn't recall much at all
she recalled and she testified in this
courtroom
and mr death never threw a can of red
bull at her
that was her testimony wasn't it
i don't recall what her testimony was
with regards to that one incident no you
actually filed a complaint against ms
lloyd's nursing license right before she
was supposedly deposed in this case
didn't you
no i don't i don't believe i did are you
aware that someone filed a complaint
against ms lloyd's nursing license in
connection with her care of mr deb for
failing to report abuse no i had no idea
you're the first person to let me know
about that
it's your testimony under out that
wasn't you
that is my testimony i didn't even know
about that until now
travis mcgivern was also present when mr
depp supposedly attacked you correct
he walked in at some point
and you heard his testimony that it was
actually you who punched mr depp isn't
that right it's always been my own
testimony that i hit johnny and and you
who was throwing things at mr dupp
i hit him in defense of my sister i
didn't have anything to throw at him i
never threw anything at him i hit him
when he attacked me and my sister
that acute not not on that occasion so
it's your testimony mr mcgregor
imagine that you were throwing things at
mr depp from the mezzanine level
down towards where mr depp and mr
mcgivern were standing well he certainly
wasn't going to say it about his client
miss heard you and mr depp kept a
journal together didn't you
yes we did you wrote each other messages
in that journal right
that is true
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 91
i'm only going to be showing you storing
portions of this so if we could please
call this plaintiff's exhibit 91a
this is the journal that you and mr depp
kept with each other in electronic form
correct that is correct and if you we
could scroll through these are all
entries that you made
in the journal correct
is it done
yes
i'm going to move for the admission of
plaintiff's exhibit 91a and i've gone
ahead and redacted mr depp's writings
as on hearsay grounds i'm going to
object okay
so
foreign
okay
let's start with the first page it's the
picture
it's the picture they haven't given me
the pages yet
writing them down
sorry judy
let's write him down first
thank you all right
if we could please publish this to the
jury
91a in evidence thank you over objection
this is a picture
that's on the inside cover of the love
notebook correct
that's correct
and this is a picture of you and mr depp
that's correct you're in australia in
this picture aren't you
yes but that's much later once we
returned
you can see that mr duff's right hand is
bandaged right
yes that's correct that was after it had
recovered significantly that's not what
it looked like uh during the incident we
were just talking about
so this is a picture after the events in
australia in march of 2015 correct yes
that photograph was taken months later
we have the jury look at that photograph
again please
let's now turn to page three
this is a note you wrote in the journal
to mr dapp correct
that's what it looks like yes
this is actually the first note you
wrote to him in this journal
i don't remember what the first note was
the date on this note is may 22nd 2015.
correct
that is correct that was during our
honeymoon period this is just a little
bit over two months after the events in
australia in march of 2015. right that's
correct we were back in a honeymoon
phase that was the period of sobriety i
spoke about yesterday when mr dub after
mr death had allegedly assaulted you
with a bottle right it was after the
stairs and it was after the australia
incident yes and he got clean and sober
and we went back to australia it's also
two months after
mr you punched mr deb because you
allegedly thought he was going to throw
your sister down the stairs right i hit
him when he swung at my sister and this
is written months later yes you thought
he was going to throw your sister down
the stairs like he had thrown kate moss
down the stairs right he swung at
whitney and i had heard a rumor a vague
rumor about that
and so it's what i thought of
this first message to mr depp in your
journal you write
quote
true love isn't about just the madness
of passion or instead picking the safety
of peace
no it's about having both falling madly
in love with your friend that is what
has surprised me perhaps the most
that i have seen in you the true bones
of friendship and respect
but of course i still
perhaps more than ever
want to rip you apart
devour you and savor the taste
fret not
xx slim
yes it's a love note
did i read that correctly yes you did
and you're slim right that's correct
that's heard i'm now going to ask you to
take a look at the very last entry you
wrote in this journal which seems to be
from april 8th
that would be april 8th 2016 correct
i'm not quite sure i don't see the year
written on there and i don't recognize
it yet
it would be a couple weeks april 8th
would be a couple weeks before your
birthday though right that's correct
just to confirm this is a note you wrote
to mr death right
that's what it looks like yes and on the
second page of this note you wrote the
following
quote
i'm sorry i can get crazy
i'm sorry i hurt you
like you i can get wicked when i am hurt
when i feel provoked shattered and last
night i was
i felt abandoned about the lily rose
thing felt absolutely bewildered about
your not coming home on my last night
here and was heartbroken and angry after
many attempts in vain on my part to
rectify the situation and make amends on
the last night of what was otherwise a
gorgeous trip with you
i am so sorry for my part none of this
is meant to be an excuse for hurting you
because the truth is nothing is there is
never a reason good enough to hurt you
you are the last thing in the whole
world who deserves it
last person i ever meant to hurt i love
you steve i am forever yours slim
did i read that correctly that's correct
mr let's take a look at defendants
exhibit 423 which is already in evidence
this is a picture of you with what
appears to be straight red marks on your
arms correct
those are scars from the broken glass
and they're straight and red right i um
i disagree with how you characterize
that um but they are red yes and they're
on your left arm
yes that's correct
mister do you have a history of cutting
yourself don't you i do not
you cut your arm once as a teenager
isn't that right no i said i wanted to
um when i was put on birth control pills
when i was a teenager i got
i felt crazy and i said i felt suicidal
it's your testimony on your oath that
you didn't report to dr hughes your
retained psychologist
that you had cut yourself as a teenager
once i said i had told my mom that i
wanted to
when i was a teenager
ms heard we heard some testimony from
you yesterday about a trip you and mr
depp took
on a train in southeast asia do you
recall that yes that's correct
that was when you and mr depp went on
your honeymoon trip correct that's
correct
and that was in july of 2015.
yes that sounds right
let's take a look at plaintiff's exhibit
162 which is already in evidence
[Music]
you were here in this courtroom right
misheard when malcolm connolly testified
to taking this picture
that's correct
this is the picture this picture shows
an injury to mr duff's face doesn't it i
disagree
i've seen this this is the truth okay
i've seen i got a picture
before and you're just not injured in it
he's not injured in this picture that's
your testimony fine this one is uh
photoshop just heard
i have your answer thank you
this is the only photograph from our
honeymoon that shows someone with an
injury correct that's not true
we haven't seen any photos of injuries
to your face from that train trip have
we
i don't believe my face was injured on
that trip
let's take a look at exhibit 91a
at page 46
going back to the love journal
this is a note from you to mr depp right
that is correct
this is a note you wrote on july 22nd
2015.
that is correct
and it starts off with the words my
husband happy honeymoon right
that's correct
it's heard please take
a look at plaintiff's exhibit 91a at
page 67.
this is another note from you to mr depp
in your journal right
that is correct and this one is dated
august 1st 2015.
that's correct
and you write that's enough you've held
this book hostage long enough
although i can't wait to read my note i
also couldn't wait to tell you how much
i adore you what a beautiful
extraordinary magical memorable
wonderful stunning surprisingly evolving
and impulsive adventure
i couldn't have imagined a more gorgeous
honeymoon
i love you more and more every passing
day
xxx slim
did i read that right that is correct
let's take a look at the journal entry
starting on page 68.
this is another entry from you
writing to mr depp right that is correct
and this one stated august 2nd
that is correct yes
and this one is a longer one so let's go
to where it ends on page 70 of the
journal
and you write quote
i hope that things said and anger and
pain were just that
and that you miss and love me too
and that
is what matters most to you you may say
you stand by everything you said and did
and that there is nothing you can learn
from this
but i don't feel that way
and it's important for me
that you know
that
i love you and i'm sorry i miss my warm
loving husband xxx slim
that is correct
and sad the word sad is crossed out
that is true
next we have a journal entry from you on
page 89.
this one's
this is another note from you to mr depp
that is correct the whole book is love
notes
so this is dated august 15th correct
that is correct and here you write quote
my love why do we fight ever why i love
you more than anything else are we that
uncomfortable with being vulnerable
were we scared or is it something else i
don't know
but i'm sure of one thing and if it's
that i can't imagine living
that i can't imagine my life without you
i love you i will do better i am sorry
x slim
did i read that correctly that is
correct
it's your testimony this was a love
journal that is correct it was primarily
love notes and
analogy notes from you to mr depp
the book was more of a love notebook um
and part of that communication obviously
since we fought so much it was important
for me to
um
you know try to nurture as much peace as
we possibly could and when things were
good they were really good
it was also an opportunity for you to
apologize to mr depp for your behavior
isn't it i think it's important in every
relationship to apologize when you're
trying to move past fights
let's look at an entry from august 17
2015 starting on page 90.
here you right quote
i'm sorry i shook the wheel so hard i'm
sorry we've tested the shocks and brakes
to this point
god damn i love you johnny i love you i
am tied to you forever you know that so
i'm tasked with making this work for
that reason and many others of which
there are many let me try to fix this
let me try to patch this
let me try to make your heart better you
deserve it hell maybe even i do i need
you we need each other you're my
cornerstone my heart my all you are my
life i hate it when we fight i hate
having you hurt
i hate that you're hurting
i love you more than anything let me
prove it i need you i love you
slim
should i read that correctly
yeah another example of me trying to fix
it
i was always trying to fix it
fix it by apologizing for your bad
behavior i tried everything i tried
apologizing i tried reading i tried
therapists i tried everything to fix it
yet you couldn't change like you told dr
cowan right i couldn't change my
relationship
let's talk about december 15 2015 again
aaron fellotti your personal nurse saw
you two days after the incident on
december 15 2015. isn't that right she
did not see me as in a medical visit she
just dropped off meds in the late at
night
she saw you personally though she
physically saw me but did not see me in
a medical sense the way a doctor might
see a patient she did not see me in that
way
she was your personal nurse right
she was a nurse assigned to me i didn't
hire her johnny did she was assigned to
you and so when she would see you it
would be physically in person in your
home and traveling correct
she would sometimes see me as like a
medical professional would and then
other times she would just drop off meds
and physically see me like as in with
her eyes
you testified that during the incident
on december 15 2015 mr depp broke the
bed correct that is correct
and more specifically described
that he broke the bed frame with his
boot while trying to get purchase is
that correct
yes that's correct
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
509 which is already in evidence
we could please have that published to
the jury thank you
mr this is a picture that you indicated
depicts a broken bed right
that's exactly it
it's your testimony that mr depp caused
this damage to the bed with his boot
right he did
is that a pocket knife on the bed there
i cannot tell what's on the bed
did you use that to damage
the bed
i did not damage the bed johnny's boot
did when he was punching me
i could feel him slipping
mr do you also testify that there was
blood all over the pillows on the bed
correct
on the pillow top yes that's correct
but you didn't take a picture of that
though did you i did not take a picture
of this
about a week after the december 15 2015
incident you went with mr depp and his
children to the island of the bahamas is
that correct
to celebrate christmas the
the incident was on the 15th and we went
on the 23rd i believe
while you were there you did a photo
shoot with greg williams correct
uh a few days later i think the photo
shoot was about two weeks after this
assault
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
99.
this is a photograph of you on mr duff's
island shortly after december 15 2015.
correct uh no this was taken weeks later
on the island on that trip it was taken
on the island
on that trip yes
weeks later weeks later december 15th
you travel to the island december 23rd
that's your time it's my recollection
that this picture was taken on new
year's eve or the first day of the year
i think new year's eve
and this is the photo shoot with greg
williams
correct that is correct
i'm going to move to admit and publish
no objection all right 99 we can publish
can we please have a
zoom in to miss hurt's face
thank you tom
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
100.
i'm going to move to admit and publish
no objection all right 100 in evidence
you can publish
miss her this is another picture of you
from that photo shoot correct
yes this is the same photo shoot that
you asked me about earlier and this is
um several weeks later right
if we could zoom in on ms heard's face
thank you tom
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
101.
and i'm going to move to admit and
publish
any objection
can we just have the foundation first
place this is a picture from the photo
shoot miss heard that was taken on the
island this is the same photo shoot yes
the no objection all right 101 and
evidence you can publish
if we could please scroll
zoom in excuse me tom on mr road's face
is your testimony misheard that you were
wearing makeup for this photo shoot
that is correct it's a photo shoot
okay
we could please pull up exhibit 102.
uh miss hurt is this another picture
from the photo shoot
i can't exactly tell from the background
it looks like it the the same thing but
i can't really tell without it being
zoomed out this is a picture of you
though right it is a picture of me yes
i'm going to move to admit and publish
all right any objection i'm not going to
object because she identified herself i
just
if she could identify uh when it was
taken that would help
but i'm not going to object
okay there we go 102 in evidence being
published
uh let's please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 103.
zero three
miss her this is yet another picture of
you
from that greg williams photo shoot
correct that is correct this is from the
same shoot gonna move to admit and
publish no objection all right 103 and
evidence publish
and again if we could zoom in on miss
herd's face
and finally if we could please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 104.
i misheard this is a picture of you from
that photo shoot correct
again this is the same photo shoot weeks
later
i'm going to move to admit and publish
no objection all right 104 in evidence
thank you
again if we could zoom in on ms hurt's
face
thank you tom
you testified that you and mr depp got
into a fight while on the island
december of 2015 correct
that's correct and this all started
because you perceived mr depp as nodding
off during the trip right
i thought he was passing out again in a
similar fashion to what he had done uh
the previous year
and and when he nodded off he spilled
wine on you correct
yeah two three times in a row you
testified that mr duff's son jack was
there when this happened right at the
beginning he was there
he was there when mr depp allegedly
spilled wine on you two or three times
right he was there for that because he
offered me help right
you also testified that mr death then
sexually assaulted you in the bathroom
correct
that's correct you testified that after
this you needed to get away from him
right
that is correct so you ran out of the
house
that's correct
and you admit you threw something at him
right i did throw something in at him to
get away
you sat in this courtroom when tara
roberts testified right misheard
i did
she's mr duff's
manager on the island
yes that's correct you heard her testify
that she witnessed an argument between
you and mr depp on the island in
december of 2015 right
i
yes that's correct yes and you heard her
testify that mr depp was trying to
escape you right
i don't know if
i don't know if she characterized it
like that but that was the gist of it
she she kind of misrepresented it to
seem like that yes she misrepresented it
how convenient that's correct okay and
then you kept apologizing to mr dub
right that's what no that's what robert
said
begging him to come back to the house
with you
that's not correct
clawing at him she used those words
that's not correct when she interrupted
us johnny had me by the hair
yelling at him
we were screaming both of us but i don't
know what she
would have heard
and that she observed an injury on mr
death's nose from something that you
threw at him right
i don't know what she observed
you also heard ms roberts testify that
she included all this information
in a sworn statement in the uk in may of
2020 isn't that right
that is correct
you put in a witness statement in
response to miss robert's statement in
june of 2020. isn't that correct in the
uk
um i made several i did several i think
seven witness statements and each one
contained different information as per
recent filings that's what council has
you do and that and in response to
previous filings correct
including testimony from people that
contradict your story sort of so what
you have to do is your counsel asks you
to respond to things and you put it in a
declaration of sorts and that happens
back and forth over the course of
preparing to go to trial in that country
and that's what i did
so that was your fifth witness statement
submitted in the uk
i don't recall which one i was asked to
comment on tara robert's testimony i'll
remind you
um if we could have ms heard's fifth
witness statement from the uk
yes ma'am
all right thank you
thank you
directing your attention is heard to
page six of your fifth witness statement
it's here that you describe
the december 2015 incident correct on
the island
uh i haven't read through the statement
i just don't know if i had commented on
it before
in a previous witness statement as i
said there were several
but starting on page six miss heard you
describe
the incident that took place on the
island correct that's correct but what
i'm trying to say is i'm not sure if i'd
describe it in full
in this statement okay
i'm going to show you
your confidential
schedule to the fifth witness statement
that accompanied the fifth witness
statement in the uk
thank you
yes ma'am
thank you
thank you
and the confidential schedule to your
fifth witness statement
paragraph
1 on page 21.
you describe mr depp sexually assaulting
you in the bahamas of december 2015
right
that is correct and that's the first
time you ever claimed that mr depp had
sexually assaulted you in the bahamas
that is incorrect
you only submitted the confidential
schedule in the uk claiming mr depp had
sexually assaulted you after miss
roberts
had said that she saw you on the island
chasing clawing at mr depp isn't that
correct that is incorrect
we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 394.
so your honor um this is another
recording i can represent to the court
this only contains mr depp and ms hurd's
voices
um i'm going to move to admit the entire
recording i'm only going to play from
one 1744 through 120 zero two all right
any objection um which which planet
exhibit you're on three nine three nine
four
i i think i have no objection all right
i'll go with that all right 394 in
evidence thank you
and since i have been doing this thing
what things have you been doing
[Music]
hence screaming
when i spilt
wine accidentally on you
for falling asleep and screaming in
front of my kids and freaking jack out
and that's trying
to appreciate yeah you're right
you're right tommy
that [ __ ] him up you know i'm sorry i
[ __ ] your son no it's it weirded him
out he'd
i [ __ ] your never up you didn't [ __ ]
my kids up but
it was pretty [ __ ] it was pretty
[ __ ] weird for him you know
[Music]
no you think you're controlling yourself
you think you're controlling yourself
especially when you use them it's
embarrassing for you i'm gonna walk away
now because you're actually
making it making me see you even worse
and believing me i'm not going to be
calling them at three o'clock in the
morning after i have an ambien and think
um i would just [ __ ] forgive me
trust me
it is
gross
[Music]
you're right meet a woman who would not
jump up and scream if she could have
been spilled on three times in a row and
i hope i hope you're happy with whoever
that is because that would be a special
kind of [ __ ] person
let's see you in mr depp in that
recording right that's correct and
you're discussing what happened in the
bahamas in december of 2015 right
uh no that's not correct we were
discussing a part of it
you're discussing
when you screamed at mr depp in front of
his children correct
no we were talking about
a part of that argument including when
you screamed at mr depp in front of his
children that's
not a fair characterization of what
happened
mr depp says you're screamed at him when
he accidentally spilled wine on you
correct i realize that's what johnny
said yeah and mr depp tells you that
this freaked out his son jack
johnny often used other people to back
him up in our arguments
don't seem too concerned about that do
you
i had a lot of concerns
you don't seem you don't
mention mr def sexually assaulting you
in this recording do you that was not
the point of that conversation if i had
gotten into the details of what happened
to me with him it would have been
another fight
you just accused mr depp of quote using
his kids right
and that required to often use other
people yes
and you challenge him to find a woman
who will not quote jump up and scream if
she has been spilled on three times in a
row
ro
that is correct
not a woman who would put up with sexual
abuse right
i was pointing out the ridiculous
nature of him expecting me not to react
to something that basic
your honor would this be a good time for
a break all right we can do that thank
you your honor all right ladies let's go
and take our morning recess for 15
minutes do not discuss the case with
anybody and don't do the outside
research we'll see in 15 okay
all right
let's go ahead and come back at 10 47
then all right 10 47. thank you
jury
okay
hmm
hey
all right thank you be seated all right
your next question
thank you your honor
ms herder you've testified repeatedly
that you were concerned about mr depp's
substance use during your relationship
right
yes that's correct but you weren't
concerned enough to stop using drugs and
alcohol yourself for you
i did not use drugs when i was with
johnny like in his presence aside from
the times i testified about with you
so you weren't concerned enough to stop
using drugs and alcohol
the times you testified to in front of
this jury right
as i testified to earlier i took drugs
um in johnny's presence on those two
occasions um early in our relationship
in 2013.
so you never change your own behavior to
support mr depp and his sobriety did you
i did a lot of changing to support his
sobriety i tried
everything that i could possibly think
of but you drank wine around mr depp on
a regular basis correct i did drink wine
and you took mr depp to hicksville to do
quote laffy drugs like mushrooms end
quote right that's correct
and you testified that despite what
supposedly happened in hicksville you
decided to take mdma with mr depp on a
plane to russia in june of 2013. correct
as i mentioned those are the two
occasions
you testified that this was the last
time you would make that mistake right
that is correct and when asked if you
would ask mr depp to get you
mdma in australia you said that was
quote ridiculous right
that is correct
because you had learned your lesson the
hard way on the plane to russia
russia yes that's correct
uh
yours and mr duff's wedding in the
bahamas was in february of 2015 right
that is correct so that would have been
after the russia flight
yes when i did um
[Music]
when we had mushrooms on the island for
my hen party my
wet bridal party before we were not with
johnny i was not with johnny at the time
was your wedding with mr depp on the
island right to be clear we were both on
the same island we just weren't
around each other that evening we had
kind of separate parties
bridal party and a groomer's party and
your wedding was a month before
australia correct
that is correct
and you arranged to have drugs at your
wedding correct
uh like i said we had mushrooms
for my bridal party beforehand
on the island for your wedding
before the wedding
on the island on the island yes okay can
we please pull up planes exhibit one two
six two
this is an email you sent on february
1st 2015 correct
that is corrupt
yes that's correct okay i'm going to
move to admit and publish
plaintiffs exhibit one two six two any
objection
yeah sure
heard's email published to the jury all
right 1262 and evidence
this is a schedule for your wedding
weekend right miss herd
no it's not it's a proposed draft of a
schedule it ended up being quite
different
do you see where it says 7 pm rehearsal
dinner
yes i see that and the next item on the
list says quote after dance party and
drugs and music
end quote right that is correct
say you plan to have drugs at your
wedding
to someone you characterize as a drug
addict
to be fair we were going to have
separate parties as i mentioned so a
bridal party before this the schedule
ended up changing quite a bit and this
is a draft clearly that was sent before
there were a lot of changes made
the bridal original idea
your original idea was to have a
rehearsal dinner with your husband the
drug addict the monster
um and then do drugs with your
girlfriends on the island after your
rehearsal dinner
i realize that's what the email suggests
but that wasn't no it's not what it
suggests or it's what you said
in that email right but what i'm trying
to say is that the schedule ended up
changing we ended up doing the little so
your original idea was to do drugs
yeah your idea original idea was to do
drugs on an island after your rehearsal
dinner to the drug field monster that
you were about to marry right the the as
the email suggests there were
there was going to be weed on the island
this does not reference the cuddle
puddle that i just referenced to you
you like to do drugs on special
occasions right ms hurd i have before
and and you did drugs again for your
30th birthday right that is correct that
was a
huge mistake
your 30th birthday dinner was on april
21st 2016.
yes it was the day before my birthday
correct you testified that mr depp was
running late to the celebration correct
that is correct you asked mr duck to
bring you alcohol when he arrived is
that right
so the utility closet where we kept the
wine was right by the elevators and i
also told him he could bring in a joint
i wouldn't bite his head off if he did
so that's a yes that's correct i i told
him i wouldn't be angry
let's look at planta's exhibit one two
six three
your i'm going to ask to show first of
all this one hasn't been produced this
has not it's a brand new trial exhibit
so i don't have it i'd like an
unredacted copy and then i'd like an
unredacted copy to be shown to the
witness do you have an unredacted copy
we can we can make one your honor okay
your honor may we approach
you
i'm going to show
the unredacted messages to um counsel
for miss heard on a laptop because i
don't have a hard copy
yeah okay we let's just
okay
someone's heard i'm only going to you
know i'm going to object to asking
questions while i'm looking at this if
you could give her a moment please sure
thank you
i'm having trouble seeing this can you
okay thanks
okay thank you all right thank you
okay okay
so
any objection 1263 as redacted no no
you're honored all right 1263 in advance
thank you thank you your honor
miss her directing your attention to the
plaintiff's exhibit 1263 this is a text
message that you sent to mr death
correct that is correct and and you sent
this message to mr depp the day you had
your 30th birthday dinner right that is
correct and you write quote hey baby
bring up something to drink
and or a joint
i'm in if you are see you in a minute
question mark xx did i read that right
that is correct
and then the next day you went to
coachella and consumed mdma mushrooms
right miss herd i did johnny was not
there for that
right
let's talk a little bit more about your
30th birthday
testified about this incident multiple
times haven't you that is correct
but yesterday you told this jury that
you were not called upon to provide a
detailed accounting of all physical and
sexual abuse by mr depp
until february 2020
is that correct
i testified that i had not been able to
do so until february 2020 in
outside of the context of a cold
deposition actually i i misspoke
february 2022 this year right sorry i i
did the same thing you did okay
and you did some you did that in
something called an interrogatory is
that correct the interrogatory response
was the first time that i could do that
outside of the context of being asked
certain questions and then deposition
and you testified about your 30th
birthday in this interrogatory correct
i believe so yes yes
nonetheless you testified to a new
detail about your 30th birthday for the
first time in this courtroom didn't you
uh no that's incorrect a sexual assault
no less
i had just not placed when that happened
i was never i was never sure if that was
the same
time that he did that on the night of my
birthday and i maintained that as well
in my deposition
you told this jury that the evening of
your 30th birthday dinner mr deb quote
grabbed you by the pubic bone pubic area
end quote and quote pushed you down
right that is correct this detail isn't
in your interrogatory response is it
misheard
that detail is in my interrogatory
response yes
let's pull up your interrogatory
response
if we could please bring up
um spread it off
thank you
okay
on it yes ma'am
thank you
thank you
if we can go to your
interrogatory responses at page 57
these are assigned under the penalty of
perjury correct that is correct
and you testified again to this jury
that this was the first time you were
given an opportunity to write down
everything and include all your evidence
right
that is correct okay so let's go to page
57
so
at the top of page 57 johnny and i were
not in a good place i begged him to make
my birthday dinner do you see that
that is correct okay so
starting on page 57 you start describing
your birthday dinner correct that is
correct
on page 59 of your interrogatory
response you write
fourth paragraph down
johnny grabbed me while holding me down
and i remember him asking me if i
thought i was so tough he asked me three
four times up close to my face you're so
tough
are you such a tough guy huh you think
you're so tough what are you gonna do
now i stood up at some point after
getting off the ground
do you see that that is correct
and then you write after i remember
crying i remember feeling exhausted and
frustrated and it hit me meaning the
realization of how sad it was that i was
going to wake up tomorrow my birthday
without him
that's correct
where in this interrogatory response ms
heard you describe mr depp
quote grabbing you by the pubic bone
pubic area and pushing you down
on page 64.
where
page 64
one two three paragraphs down
johnny grab me once did this taunting
thing on the side of the bed in
penthouse 3. he grabbed my vagina and
held me there asked me if i was so tough
you're not describing what happened
after your 30th birthday i am i just had
not prescribed it to that date with the
limited
evidence i had at the time only in the
course of looking at the evidence
preparing for this case have i put those
two pieces together
but i've always said what happened
you were upset that mr depp was late to
your 30th birthday weren't you
i was
you knew mr dub had a scheduled business
meeting or a money meeting that evening
right
no i knew he said he did i didn't know
if he had one addict's life all the time
so you didn't trust him
i took it with the big grain of addict
salt okay
mr death texted you that evening to let
you know he'd be late correct
yes he did text me at some point
it was a big deal to you that mr depp
was late to your birthday dinner wasn't
it
yeah yeah it did matter to me you were
upset he was late i was i was hurt and
when he finally did arrive he felt quote
invisible to him right i did
the day after your birthday dinner you
and your friends went to coachella to
celebrate your birthday is that correct
that is correct
you made a video driving to coachella
with your friends didn't you that is
correct i'd like to pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1264
and for the record your honor this only
has um
music without any words on it
and again it's a new one so i'd like a
copy of it
it's going to be played
there there is no sound other than a
song yes sure
with a sound
this is the video you made when you
drove to coachella with your friends
after your 30th birthday right that's
correct i'm not quite sure which one of
us made the video but that's correct
you're featured in that video driving
that's correct
and it's set to the song miss you by the
rolling stones is that right that's
correct that was a message for mr depp
wasn't it
no that's ridiculous
you consumed drugs at coachella didn't
you
yes i did
you took mdma and mushrooms at the same
time i i did yes and it made you feel
sick right i felt horrible yes so you
left coachella yes that's correct you
testified yesterday yesterday that when
you left coachella you left with quote
your entire group
that is correct and you were quote never
alone with starling right that is
correct you weren't anywhere near him
not alone no
you sat here when sterling jenkins
testified that he collected you from
coachella when you were sick right
he picked up my entire group
mr jenkins testified quote i collected
her got her in the vehicle she didn't
want anyone else to know that she was
sick take her back to the parker which i
assume was in reference to the hotel
alone
i took her to 7-eleven where i retrieved
hydrating fluids advil and let her have
those got her back up to the parker got
her in the suite and then went back to
pick up everyone else
you were there when mr jenkins testified
right yes he was wrong so it's your
testimony that mr jenkins is lying he's
just wrong i don't know what his
intentions are he was just wrong about
that we were a big group of us i wasn't
alone with him
isn't it possible that you don't
remember correctly because you were sick
from taking mdma mushrooms at the same
time
i remember everything about that night
okay
i'd like to play for you plaintiff's
exhibit
one two two nine which is already in
evidence at 17 20 through 21 28.
okay
and that's what i came to figure out
we
i didn't want you to [ __ ] go to
coachella without [ __ ] talking to me
because i left you because you you were
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] hangmackered me man you came
around the bed and [ __ ] start
punching on me
[Music]
that's what really happened the evening
of your 30th birthday isn't it misheard
no that's incorrect mr duff was in bed
and then you came around the bed and
started punching him that's incorrect
you don't deny that in the recording do
you miss heard i'm not having that
conversation with johnny i'm not denying
anything i'm not saying anything i'm not
having that conversation with johnny i
was trying to get out of that hotel room
uh that was a mediation attempt that was
the recording you just heard it was us
meeting in a hotel
but you're talking about your 30th
birthday no we're not you're not talking
about going to coachella and
johnny's talking about that i am not
arguing with him about any of that right
you don't deny anything do you i'm not
talking to him about that
i'm going to um
publish exhibit or ask that the witness
be shown exhibit one two six five
this is you and your friends at
coachella correct that is correct i'm
gonna move to admit plaintiffs one two
six five and publish it no objection all
right one two six five in evidence you
can publish it
it's no injuries to you are there
misheard visible in this picture you
cannot see any visible injury no
thank you tom
mister do you remember during mr duff's
examination a number of recordings were
played correct that's correct
and in one of those recordings you told
mr depp quote i hope to god jack's stop
father teaches him more about being a
man than you're [ __ ] your [ __ ]
left nut end quote do you remember that
i do not remember what exactly i could
hear of that recording i remember i
heard heard myself make a mention of uh
jack's new stepfather or
potential step-father i can't recall
jack is mr depp's son right that is
correct and i believe that the i was
referencing a marriage that his
ex-partner was going to have or getting
into i suppose
you were referencing that
jack's new stepfather would teach him
how to be a man because mr depp couldn't
i don't recall exactly what i said but
it was something to that effect
let's listen to some of what happened
before you said that uh to mr depp um if
we could please play plaintiff's exhibit
397 which is already in evidence and for
the record it's at 3504
through 3547
and then the next clip is 3635
through 4308
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and when it doesn't go away
i'm in trouble
you know what suck i don't need you i
don't want you
i don't want you kind of one of them i
don't want you coming not my dick
bought into any of your [ __ ] lives
your [ __ ] your sober [ __ ]
presence your [ __ ] goodness your
sweetness all the lies i wish i hadn't
bought into the months of you being you
i wish i bought promises i wish i
[ __ ] thought i could have kids with
you you're a [ __ ] kid yourself i wish
i hadn't bought into any of the lives
you still talk about fake bill and goods
you're the biggest [ __ ] seller of
fake [ __ ] good talk about presenting
yourself i did myself the fake sound
like good
i [ __ ] you you you've left nothing
and i've left everything so suck your
dick
which is probably your next move
we'll go get it now
actually
yoga vlogs
[Music]
i'm sure she's crazy
[Music]
oh
what else what else other things do you
want to addre
[Music]
wait is there no other place for you to
run in your 15 other houses to go run
come on go be a real married man who
deals your [ __ ] the way that a man does
go run to the next house
every man does
go
run away i know what's happening you're
[ __ ] ridiculous crying
hard panicked [ __ ] clown hard it's
hard screwing
[Laughter]
you've got everybody out here almost
full but it don't last you're right
longer you're right
you're
right to that whoa i wonder what we all
i don't know what else we can reach for
in the last 16 minutes
oh no it was four years ago you're right
there's other things you could
[Music]
no i know that's shipping
well there's always that you can you're
right you can write a book you can write
a book oh you know you can write a book
oh is this going to be good for your
book
oh
should i have you signed an apa for your
book
your
[Music]
you don't want to sell out or anything
let's tell you journals
oh
wait
hey hey you know no you're not watching
no no you're not selling you want to
show up oh my god
yeah
no one does jump 21 drunk stream when
they're in their 20s no you're right
that's not going out no
when you're in your 20s you should
really know what you want like selling
your journals
if you didn't if you didn't know who you
thought
i don't know it doesn't matter at this
point
i don't think so
i don't really think so
but you're right i mean hey
at least i didn't do like
a tv show where i was hurtful
in my 20s god that would be like
embarrassing
if only i was with someone in their 50s
i could point that out to me imagine
mine you're right when you play a
non-sexualized object oh okay
wow
you're right you got one you got it i'll
figure it out
i don't even know what movies are done
you haven't even taken them
yeah i'm the joke in the industry amber
[Music]
i'm sorry
the re-runs of all my [ __ ] are
playing too loud for me to hear you i'm
gonna just go and
pedal my way back
i cared
you're jealous he's so tragic
you're jealous he's so tragic
[ __ ] like
thinking that i'm going on a road with
that batman
i can't hear you
told mr
dab to suck your dick multiple times
didn't you yes i did you tell him to go
run to his 15 other houses right that's
correct
because that's what he would do when you
behave like this isn't it
eventually he would
go and stay in one of the other houses
you call him a sellout don't you
i was expressing frustration
uh about
his criticism of my career and how many
problems that cost within the dynamic of
our relationship yes so you call them a
sellout and a joke i call them horrible
ugly things as you can hear sell out we
spoke to each other in a really horrible
way
pretty sure
we just heard you speak to him in a
really horrible way you called him a
sellout i just missed her um you called
him a sell-out right miss hurt i called
him a lot of ugly things and a joke i
called him a lot of ugly things he
called him a joke on that recording he
called him a washed up piece of [ __ ] i
think we both called each other that on
that uh occasion yes mr depp mentions
aquaman doesn't he yes he does sir i got
you that role in aquaman didn't he
excuse me mr depp
got you that role in aquaman didn't he
no miss vasquez i got myself that role
by auditioning
that's true that says quote your
jealousy is so tragic
i heard him say that yes
you were the jealous one in this
relationship weren't you misheard i
think he was indicating i was jealous of
his career
but now you've twisted it to say it was
mr depp that's the jealous one
johnny's always been very jealous when i
worked when i did anything friends yes
he's always been very jealous
and sir i'm going to ask you to take a
look at plants exhibit one two zero
e this is a series of text messages
between you and mr depp
that is correct
i'm going to move to admit
and publish these text messages
um mr duff's messages have been redacted
all right any objection no you're on it
all right 120e in evidence you can
publish
it starts with a text message from you
to mr depp on september 26 2015 right
that is correct
you write monster is back this is him
did i read that right that is correct
and then in the next message you write
quote
ran away first sign of trouble this is
not the man you promised you would be
did i read that correctly
that is correct
then in the next one down you write
promise
swore to me you would be
that is correct
the non-monster
miss heard you're talking about mr dot
running away from you at the first sign
of trouble aren't you no i'm um i'm
recognizing the clues at this point when
he would
run away at the first sign of trouble
often that was a clue for me to know
that he was back using again and that we
were about to enter the next phase of
the cycle and you describe his running
away from you as the monster right that
wasn't what was a monster the monster
was the man who beat me up the running
away was just attached to that it was a
sign a signal to me as a clue
as somebody trying to put together clues
um that we were entering into into that
base but in these messages ms heard
youngster isn't mr depp doing drugs is
it it was always um the man who did
drugs and beat me up yes that's always
been the monster
that's not what you're saying in these
messages that is exactly what i'm saying
in the messages you don't describe mr
dot being violent do you
i do not describe that in this text
message no
so it's a cowardly monster this time
no
okay
and going down the page you write a long
series of text messages to mr deb
that don't get a response is that
correct
that is correct
you write come groan face the [ __ ] and
we can do anything
you go on a little later to say please
come home let's apologize to
each together
and continuing on page 77 you write
not go to bed mad
and then you say sound okay
sound like the priority in the long run
come home
don't be the monster be the man
please
please call me
please
continuing on page 78
you're right i don't want the monster i
need my man
i need to talk to you
please johnny
don't force me to be something else to
you
this is taking me for granted and i can
never stop
before this turns into something far
darker
describing yourself in that text message
right the exact opposite i'm trying to
interrupt him starting a new cycle where
he starts using again he's not
responding to you ms heard
yeah that's why i'm trying to
desperately stop him
please answer the phone you say
doesn't this mean anything to you
and it goes on and i won't read all
these messages but you're saying please
answer over and over again
right it was very important to me
i was running out of time and i was
trying desperately to stop him
he wasn't with you miss heard exactly
which is how i knew it was about to get
a lot worse
he would leave use and come back way
worse with way less reality with more
delusions he'd be more drunk
everything after i was trying to stop
the answer to her question
she was responding
i'll
overrule the objection that's fine thank
you this is a situation where you were
trying to get mr depp to pay attention
to you isn't that right no i was trying
to stop him from using and because he
ran away from you at the first sign of
trouble you call him a monster i was
trying to stop him from turning into the
monster the drugs that are the key that
opened the door who was the real monster
in this relationship ms heard
lives in johnny half of johnny it's not
all of johnny the other half of him is
wonderful and beautiful and the man i
love
i'd like you to take a look at
plaintiff's exhibit 120f
[Music]
there's another set of text messages
between you and mr depp is that correct
yes that's correct i'm going to move to
admit and publish any objection no
you're on all right 120f and evidence
you can publish
this is a set of text messages and it's
from october 2015. do you see that yes i
do
in fact you sent all these messages
to mr depp on october 22nd 2015. isn't
that right exactly same thing was
happening here
and again i'm not going to read them all
but you start off again by trying to get
mr depp's attention right you right
please come home
i was trying to stop another bender
you're right please come home right that
is correct please answer don't break us
up
please answer please
and continuing on page 97 you write
give me some piece of your heart
please no fight i promise
please
no fights
please just pick up
please give me two minutes
i'm dying
please
and continuing on page 98 you write
please come home
please come home baba
i am so sorry
actually you didn't say baba you said
baby apologies
and it goes on
did i read those correctly that is
correct that was another time i'm trying
to stop another twist off
this is what would happen when mr depp
would try to take some space from you
right no this is what would happen when
johnny had moved into the next phase of
the cycle decided to use and our lives
were getting a lot worse just heard i'm
talking about your actions
this is what you would do to mr depp
when he would leave you you would hurray
with him i would try not correct
him
your honor at least let her answer the
question
that's fine good to answer the question
i do not think uh i would characterize
my behavior that way i was trying to
stop him from using it you were texting
him incessantly isn't that correct
misheard it was imperative for my life
my question is to me much more simple
you were texting him incessively i would
yes or no everything to get a hold of
him and to stop the cycle
that's a yes right i would try
everything to stop the cycle it was that
important to me and he's the monster for
not responding to you that's not what
made him the monster for needing space
from you
the monster was not the guy who needed
space the monster was who he was when he
came back not for doing drugs misheard
not for being violent just for needing
space that's when you called mr depp the
monster incorrect
let's listen to defendants exhibit 598c
which is already in evidence
and let's not do this anymore because
i'm really getting frustrated and i'm
really really really sick of this
argument i'm sorry okay so let me go and
you go and i'll speak to you in a couple
hours
okay
okay
why are you saying stop may i go it
causes me so much stress when you leave
when you walk away from me with that
it's like you're you don't understand
how much worse you're making this
please you're making it worse for me
okay i'm sorry for you
please i'm only trying to tell you
too that you know
you're causing immense stress right now
when you walk away like that
there's no reason to be mad i can say
goodbye
i haven't walked away you're not saying
goodbye you won't let me [ __ ] leave
let me leave
stop rushing me stop pushing me in the
corner and then poking me with this dick
and then saying why are you saying the
words you want me to say
stop poking me stop rushing me stop
throwing me against the wall going what
you like that wall you don't like the
[ __ ] wall
stop pushing me remember i'm not pushing
you
i'm rushing you i said i need space
i don't want this conversation anymore
right now i need space and i will take
my space whether you like it or not
i will take it
and you will take your space
but if you keep
halting i'm not doing this and
continuing i'm not ready
i'm begging you to stop i don't okay
stop just i'm stopped
stop
now i have to go
okay so we will speak to each other in a
couple of hours
okay
i'll give
some kind of
revelation
makes you feel better
you know i hope i do too but uh we'll
just see when i get home and just talk
or we won't talk or we you know we'll
finish this or we won't finish it
but this is not bro this is not
happiness this is not
please stop
doing this please you're
so much [ __ ] stressed i'm gonna die
i'm gonna [ __ ] die you're causing me
so much dress please stop
please
i feel like i have heart attacks almost
every day please stop please stop doing
it please don't be so [ __ ] me
[ __ ] bully stop
please stop i've been begging you not to
fight i just said can we please have a
normal argument just even though normal
conversation is like a normal argument
and for the last hour i've been begging
you to please just leave it at that
let's just go on with our night i would
have been able to come in with you we
would have been able to let it go in a
few minutes it would have been fine it
would just if we loud ourselves have
[ __ ] normal arguments
please you're killing me with this
you're killing me
you're
[ __ ] killing me yeah [ __ ]
sean
could you uh
please
i want you to just go i want you to take
your medicine
or whatever i'm sorry that i've upset
you i think
thank you sean i'm ready to go thank you
so much
i'm really ready
you and mr depp in the recording correct
mister that's correct you just won't let
him go will you that's not true we were
outside of his studio and he wanted to
go and use it was a pretext the
the claim that he was upset with me was
a pretext so that he would go and go on
a bender i knew that pattern by the time
this recording happened
it's your testimony now that you were
outside mr depp's studio
i believe that the hub is going to work
excuse me he was going to go use drugs
that's your testimony now
we were outside his studio his man cave
house if you will in the car i believe
during that recording
and he was going to go inside and use
that was the pattern and as you can hear
from my voice i'm
very very very scared of
entering into the next cycle under
under what i had been conditioned to
understand we were at at that point in
our relationship that's not true is it
misheard mr depp was trying to go inside
his house to see his daughter lily rose
she might have been over that day but
that's not your testimony
to do and that's not what i was stopping
him from doing okay
let's play the beginning part of that
recording where mr depp tells you that
he wants to go inside to see his
daughter
and let's not do this anymore because
i'm really getting frustrated and i'm
really really really sick of this
argument i'm sorry okay so let me go and
you go and i'll speak to you in a couple
hours
okay
okay
why are you saying stop may i go
we'll circle back to this but it's your
testimony that you were outside mr
death's studio we were in the car you
were in the car outside of mr dev studio
that's correct and he wasn't telling you
please let me go inside my house to see
my daughter he was
indicating to you that he wanted to go
inside to do drugs that's your testimony
i know my testimony is that i knew what
he was going inside to go do i knew what
stage of the cycle we were in i knew the
patterns fight in and i was desperately
out of time trying to interrupt that
cycle
let's go to may of 2016.
uh yesterday i must heard uh miss
bredehoff your attorney showed you
certain pictures um
from may 21 2016. do you remember that
yes i do
if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 710 which has already been
admitted
into evidence
miss heard you testified yesterday that
this is a photograph taken of you on may
21 2016. do you recall
yes that's correct keeping this exhibit
up if we could please do a split screen
tom and also pull up defendants exhibit
714 which has already been admitted with
redactions
you started you testified yesterday that
this is the photograph that was also
taken on may 21st 2016 correct
yes although the one to the right might
have been taken the next uh day i can't
be sure the reason i say that is because
there's light in the background so
it looks like it was taken in the
daytime which means maybe it was the
next day didn't you testify that you uh
took
different lighting pictures in different
lightings
that is correct yes
and and you're wearing two thin
necklaces in this picture on the right
is that correct that is correct you
testified that these pictures were taken
the same night
the one on the right looks like it was
taken in the daytime because i can see
the daylight behind me
but you testify that they were taken the
same day
uh i don't know if i
i think i testified that they came from
the same incident of the same day not
necessarily taken on the same day okay
let's please pull up defendants exhibit
seven one two
which has already been admitted
uh you testified yesterday this is
another photograph of you on the night
of may 21.
that's correct and keeping this exhibit
up can we please do a split screen and
also pull up defendants 713 which has
already been admitted
miss heard you testified yesterday this
is also a photograph of you from the
same night correct that is correct you
testified yesterday that the only
difference between these two photographs
is that the light was turned on
that's what it appears to be yes
the light is on on both of these
pictures though isn't that right it
looks to me like the one on the left has
the vanity light the makeup lights you
know the more yellow hued ones that go
around the mirror on and then the one on
the right looks like it doesn't have
those
isn't it true you just edited these
photographs no i've never edited a
photograph didn't you just enhance the
saturation for one of these photos to
make your face look
more red
no that's incorrect i didn't touch it
you were sitting here in this courtroom
when mr isaac varus testified to see you
seeing you the week after may 21
correct i was here mr burush testified
that he saw you on may 22nd while you
were changing the locks of your
penthouse do you recall that testimony i
do i just don't know if he was right
about the date but i do remember him
saying that
testified it was his birthday the day
after his birthday
i believe it was yeah
mr burroughs testified that he saw you
repeatedly in the days following also
correct that's correct
and mr baruch testified that he saw no
marks or injuries on your face correct
that is what he's testified to
you we're also here in this court when
mr sean bette testified to seeing you on
the evening of may 21 2016. is that
right
you were here
that's correct mr bett also testified
that he saw no marks or injuries on your
face that evening correct i realize
that's what he said
you were sitting here in this courtroom
when officer melissa science testified
by deposition
about being called to the eastern
columbia building on may 21st 2016.
right i saw her testimony yes and you
heard officer signs testify that she did
not see any injuries on you that night
correct i heard her testify she did not
consider this injured
no
miss officer signs testified that she
met with you and she did not see any
injuries
on your face isn't that correct she did
not consider this injury
misheard my question is a bit more
nuanced
so is my answer
all right
tom can we put these down please
i think they might be confusing the
witness
my question is more nuanced
you sat in this courtroom
while officer science testified
that she saw you the night of may 21
2016
face to face
and didn't see any injuries on your face
isn't that correct miss heard i believe
she was testifying
about these photographs and she said
that i was not injured in them
is it your testimony under oath now that
officer signs testified that she saw
injuries on you when she saw you in
person on may 21. sorry let me clarify i
was testifying that i know that that's
what officer science said that she
didn't consider my red puffy face
injured that's what she said
the red puffy face that was your
council's question correct that was your
testimony in the uk
that's incorrect and you know that
misheard
i disagree it's just inconvenient for
you that officer science didn't see
injuries on you on may 21 2016. it
doesn't matter what's convenient for me
right
officer tyler hadden also testified by
deposition about being called to the
eastern columbia building on may 21 2016
and
he also testified no injuries on your
face on may 21 2016 isn't that correct
they both said that they did not
consider me injured
they did not see injuries on your face
on may 21 2016. isn't that what their
testimony was what their testimony was
is that they did not consider what my
face looked like to be injury they
didn't consider what they walked on in
the house damage but it was
you were sitting here when officer
william gatlin testified by deposition
about being called on
may 21 to the eastern columbia building
and he also did not observe any injuries
on you did he
and that's what he testified to he
didn't even know which one i was
no i think we all saw on video camera
you identify yourself isn't that correct
i had to because of how far away he was
he didn't even know he didn't even know
who he was after you identified yourself
he looked at you isn't that correct from
a distance yes
and he didn't see any visible injuries
either did he i don't know what he saw
he testified that he didn't see any
visible injuries i would believe that he
didn't yes
you were also in this courtroom when
alejandra romero who worked at the front
desk at the eastern columbia building
testified about seeing you on may 25th
2016. isn't that correct
that is correct i think he said the 25th
yeah and mr romero testified that he
didn't see any swelling or bruises on
your face when you were talking to him
at the front desk he wouldn't have
no he wouldn't have even though he had a
habit because his
parents taught him correctly to look
into someone's eyes when speaking to
them isn't that correct i know that's
what he testified to yes
testified yesterday that you sought a
temporary restraining order on may 27
2016 because you wanted to change your
locks do you remember that testimony yes
i do
because the locks were to the penthouse
is at the eastern columbia building
isn't that correct that's correct
you changed the locks to the penthouses
on may 22nd 2016. i attempted to
that's why you felt comfortable having
james franco over the evening of may
22nd 2016 miss heard i do not know when
i do not know when james came over okay
let's remind you can we please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 304 which is already
in evidence and play
from 254 through 439
um
[Music]
uh
that's you and mr franco on may 22nd
2016 right miss heard that's correct and
you're taking him up to the penthouses
aren't you that's where i lived yes and
it's past 11 p.m at night isn't that
right i'm not quite sure the time it
looked it looked like that
why don't we pull that video back up
22 51
almost midnight right that's excuse me
almost 11 o'clock at night exactly
okay
you knew mr depp was out of town the
week of may 21 2016 didn't you
i don't know what i knew of his schedule
at the time
knew mr depp was out of town on may 27th
when you went to get the domestic
violence restraining order isn't that
right i don't know if i knew that at the
time
you knew you knew mr depp was heading
out on a european tour that week isn't
that right i'm not quite sure what i
understood of his schedule at that time
you knew he wouldn't be back for weeks
right no that's incorrect
let's uh go back to that recording
it's a defendant's exhibit 598.
do you testified that
you and mr depp were in the car
outside of his studio is that right yes
you were trying to prevent him from
going into his studio to do drugs right
uh yeah to effectively start another
cycle right
not that mr depp was just trying to go
into his house to see his daughter right
his daughter might be one of the people
that was in the house at that time but
that's
neither here nor there though testimony
is now from entering a cycle
your testimony is now that mr does drugs
in front of his children
well first of all i know he does um
second of all
it wouldn't have mattered it wouldn't
have stopped him from using with his
friends which is the problem not whether
or not his daughter was there okay
um let's play please defendants 598 at
49 48 through 50 35.
50 35.
i'm not i'm itching i don't want to be
doing this
i want it just to why don't you just say
okay baby i understand i'll go home and
you do your thing hang out with your
daughter and then i'll see you in a
couple hours and we'll talk about it
is it that difficult to say that or you
just [ __ ] hate me and you want to be
shitty about it
please
just [ __ ]
it's not that difficult
okay
i don't want to stand here in a driveway
and argue with you
okay well
i'll shoot a little bit okay
please
please
just let me know if you're gonna go
somewhere just let me know please so i
know
and almost an hour later you're still
arguing with mr depp outside right i
don't know how long that argument lasted
no okay
mister you testified about seeking a
domestic violence or syrian order
against mr depp correct
yes i have and how you wanted to do it
discreetly
that's correct
that you wanted as much privacy as you
could have yes that's correct and how
you walked out to a sea of paparazzi and
cameras and photographers right
that is correct
and how this overwhelmed you
it was overwhelming yes because you
didn't want this attention on you
that is correct
if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 800 which has already been
admitted into evidence
this is a photograph of you taken inside
the courthouse when you obtain the dvro
correct
that's correct and your friend raquel
pennington took this photograph
yes that's correct because you needed to
document your time at the courthouse
getting a dvro
she just took a picture of me i
i'm assuming it was um
in relation to my divorce yeah
if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 801 which has already been
admitted into evidence
miss her this is another photograph of
you taken inside the court house isn't
that right that is correct
were you having a photo shoot inside the
courthouse while you were getting a dvro
i would not characterize it that way
miss vasquez
you have a mark on your face right
misheard yes
didn't use your bruise kit this time to
cover it up no i was the only day i
actually walked out of my house without
makeup on i had to be stopped my best
friend saw me in the bathroom starting
to put makeup on and told me not to
all right
can we please pull up exhibit one
that's plaintiffs at one yes thank you
your honor apologies it's already been
admitted into evidence
you wrote this op-ed right miss heard
with the help of the aclu yes
that's what you testified to in this
courtroom right that is correct
and this was published on december 18
2018 correct
that is correct
aquaman was released on december 21st
2018 right that is yes that sounds
correct
that was your first
big
blockbuster big budget role right
i disagree but it was the first time i
had like a
a leading role in a movie of that size
yes
well second time
yes what was your first time the first
one was the film i talked about before i
mean yesterday um justice league it
introduced the character so
you know technically it was the second
one
but you were the love interest in
aquaman correct that is correct
now at least parts of this op-ed are
about mr depp isn't that right
it's about what happened to me after
you sat here during opening statements
when your attorney argued that the
context of your statements in this op-ed
matter correct
that's correct so let's go through some
of that context
he wrote here quote
friends and advisors told me i would
never work again as an actress that i
would be blacklisted
referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp in the
statement aren't you
can you repeat the question i'm sorry
you're referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp
in the statement aren't you
um in general i'm referring to being
associated with domestic violence
and you're referring to what you claim
happened after you got an ex-party
domestic violence restraining order
against mr depp in may of 2016 right
are you asking me if that's what i was
writing about
that's what you're referring to correct
can you just give me the question again
i'm sorry you're referring to what you
claim happened after you got an ex-party
restraining order against mr depp in may
of 2016. that's correct
you also wrote
questions arose as to whether i would be
able to keep my role of mira in the
film's justice league and aquaman
this is also
referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp right
this is referring to what happened to me
after i got my tro my restraining order
against mr depp right that is correct
these questions arose only after you
accused mr depp of domestic violence in
may of 2016 allegedly right
yeah from the time i got the tro being
associated with domestic violence that's
what it's a reference to yes
you also wrote quote
imagine a powerful man as a ship like
the titanic that ship is a huge
enterprise when it strikes an iceberg
there are a lot of people on board
desperate to patch up holes not because
they believe in or care about the ship
but because their own fates depend on
the enterprise
in this op-ed you're saying mr depp is a
ship right
i'm making an analogy to a powerful man
as a ship
the powerful man you're referring to and
this analogy is mr depp right
i was talking about
a bigger issue actually than just johnny
i was talking about what we as a
as a country were talking about at the
time of writing this which is
when powerful men in general do
something
horrible or something they shouldn't how
there is a system in place to protect
them clean up after them maintain them
uh afloat you know this is
a reference to not just johnny it was
about
what was happening as a culture when we
were addressing a lot of metoo issues
for the first time the iceberg is you in
this analogy right miss herd
um i would not say that i had that had
not
that was not what i intended to know
so
this is another reference to your
accusations against mr death
uh
no this is about what happened to me
once i left
uh that relationship and got a tro and
became associated with domestic violence
right
but it's your testimony that this op-ed
isn't about mr death right it's about
what happened to me after that's correct
about your experience after obtaining a
temporary restraining order against mr
depp right that is correct among other
things but it's not about mr death it is
not about him mr depp is making it about
mr duff right
ironically
it's kind of like that carly simon song
right miss herd
i don't know what you mean
let's talk about the defamatory
statements in the op-ed that you also
claim are not about mr depp
then two years ago i became a public
figure representing domestic abuse and i
felt the full force of our culture's
wrath for women who speak out
this is about mr death isn't it
no
you wrote this in 2018 right exactly
and two years prior was 2016 right
that's true okay that's correct it's not
about johnny it's about what happened
my question was may of 2016 is two years
prior to december of 2018. that's
correct all right
may 2016 is when you publicly accuse mr
depp of domestic violence right
i got my restraining order at that time
and you publicly accused mr depp of
domestic violence yes that was in attach
my restraining order so yes
may of 2016 is when you sought a
restraining order against mr depp that's
right correct and i had to provide
testimony for that right and may 2016 is
when you walked into court with a mark
on your face to obtain that restraining
order yes or no
that was the day i walked into court
with a bruise on my face yes
and you were photographed with that mark
on your face weren't you i walked out to
a bunch of photographers cs may 2016 is
when you told the world that mr depp had
physically abused you during your
relationship isn't that right
that i had to provide testimony as part
of my restraining order application yes
and that's how you became a public
figure representing domestic abuse right
misheard from that point on yes that's
when you claimed you faced our culture's
wrath that's when it started yes but
it's your testimony under oath that this
statement is not about mr depp it is uh
not it is about what happened to me
afterwards that's the more interesting
was the more interesting thing for me to
write about
the next statement reads
i had the rare vantage point of seeing
in real time how institutions protect
men accused of abuse
this is also about mr depp isn't that
right
not just about him but he is included in
that yes he's the man you accused of
abuse two years prior to this op-ed
isn't that right miss heard yes but i
wrote this op-ed in the context of many
men at the time that were public figures
are in this public eye being accused as
well so it was a reference in general to
a larger phenomenon not just johnny
not just johnny not just johnny
okay
and then
you write i spoke up against sexual
violence and faced her culture's wrath
this one's also about mr depp
i did not write that
well you've accused mr sexual violence
in this very courtroom haven't you yes
but i i was intending to keep that
private when this was published i
i had not
publicly ever accused him of that i'm
going to move to strike everything after
the word yes
that's
over with objection go ahead
you may not have written this title but
you published it didn't you
i did not publish a title i retweeted
the article that included the title in
it because that was the article let's
pull up please plaintiffs exhibit three
which is already in evidence
this is a tweet from your twitter
account on december 19 2018 correct that
is correct
you're on our i'm
oh it's already in evidence it is an
evidence
thank you so on december 19 2018 you
tweeted quote today i published this
op-ed in the washington post did i read
that right that is correct and the tweet
includes a link to the op-ed we were
just looking at correct that's correct
and you can see that the title of the
op-ed in your tweet is quote opinion
amber heard i spoke up against sexual
violence
right
yes you don't get to change the title of
an article you're retweeting
and that's the title that you put on
your twitter correct i did not put it on
my twitter no you linked it to your
tweet i i retweeted the article
you published it
i retweeted a link to an article that
i wrote and you publish it on your
twitter account all right i retweeted it
you testified yesterday that you didn't
have any control over the title and just
now
of the op-ed when you retweeted it is
that correct that is correct
this wasn't a retweet though right
um a tweet
perhaps not retweet i don't i'm not
quite sure it was a tweet tweet
i'm misspoke excuse me tweet not retweet
you included a link to the electronic
copy of the op-ed in your tweet right
that's what i was trying to say earlier
um and i might have misspoke it's like
i'm trying to attach it right
so you can cr included a link right yes
that's correct okay that's correct
so you must have seen the title the
electronic version of the op-ed before
you tweeted it right i may have i just
didn't notice it
not very careful about what you
published are you misheard
i just didn't notice the title
you didn't need to include the link to
the electronic version the op-ed in your
tweet did you how else would i have
linked it
well you didn't need to include the link
to tell the world that today you had
published this op-ed in the washington
post about women who are challenging
their rage and about violence and
equality into political strength despite
the price of coming forward
right i couldn't attach it with a paper
clip no but you didn't need to attach it
at all to tell the world that you had
published an op-ed no the goal was to to
tweet about it and to provide a link so
that people could read it the op-ed is
in your name right that's correct
so if you had noticed the title of the
electronic version of the op-ed before
you included it in your tweet you could
have asked the washington post to change
it isn't that right
uh no that's not okay but you didn't do
that right you never asked the
washington post to change the title i
didn't notice it and i didn't ask them
nor do i think i needed to
at the bottom do you see that there's
another tweet from december 19
2018 yes i do
and in this one
it reads i am honored to announce my
role as an aclu ambassador on women's
rights did i read that right that's
correct so you announced your aclu
ambassadorship the same day you posted
the op-ed on your twitter i think that
was always the plan is to attach the
article with the anna uh the
announcement that i was an ambassador
your honor if
i may
uh would this be a good time to stop for
lunch no it's too early okay sorry it's
okay we gotta keep going at least till
12 30. okay good thank you thank you
mr you testified yesterday about your
counter claim against mr depp in this
case do you remember that testimony
uh yes i do your counter claim is based
on three statements made by mr depp's
attorneys adam waldman is that right
that's correct
we looked at those three statements
yesterday right that's correct and the
first statement was from an april 8th
2020 article right
that's correct
and that's defendant's exhibit one two
four five that's been previously
admitted
please
pull that up thank you
we could please publish that thank you
we can scroll down to the eighth page
mr dubs excuse me mr waldman's statement
is buried on the eighth page of a
12-page article is that right misheard i
don't know how many pages are here well
that's this is the eighth page
let's go to the 12.
let's pull up please defendants exhibit
one two four six which has already been
admitted
and if we could please go to mr
woldman's statement on page 10
and go on to page 11 of a
that's mr waldman's statement right that
is correct
uh i think it's
um mr waldman speaking on behalf of
johnny yes
you don't have any evidence of that do
you misheard this is mr waldman's
statement right i think it's included in
the article as well
that this is mr waldman's statement
correct that a a representative or an
attorney i don't know which word it says
in the article that it says it says very
clearly that they're speaking on behalf
of johnny or representing johnny
um can we please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit
8818 881a
excuse me
we could please go to
page
eight
of this article
[Music]
sorry your honor yeah i just approached
yes ma'am
uh
we'll come back to this sorry i miss
heard i'm sorry your honor
let's go ahead and take this down please
thanks you testified yesterday about how
your reputation was before these three
statements were made correct
uh yes i did
okay you testified that your career was
going very well
before i think i said the trajectory was
positive yes you testified you had a
global campaign for l'oreal right that
is correct you testified you were
waiting on a schedule for aquaman two
that is correct you testified you were
scheduled to do a press tour for the tv
show the stand
press obligations yes and then you
testify that after the articles you were
no longer actively involved in the
l'oreal campaign isn't that right they
suspended using my material and that you
were no longer involved in the publicity
surrounding the stand after the articles
right
that's correct
and you didn't hear anything about the
schedule for aquaman 2
correct
ms heard you have no evidence that mr
waldman's three statements are the
reason you are allegedly no longer
active in the l'oreal campaign do you
um
well i mean other than
my awareness that they can't use me
because of all of the
online
attention that generated
and you have no evidence that mr
willman's three statements are the
reason that the stand media
opportunities allegedly stop do you yeah
i know they couldn't attach
my name to their promotional materials
because of the online stuff
in fact there was a lot of reasons why
you were no longer active in these
endeavors isn't that right
um i disagree with that
reasons that had absolutely nothing to
do with mr waldman's statements isn't
that right uh i disagree with that there
was a lot of publicity about your
relationship with mr depp around the
time mr waldman made the three
statements at issue right
uh i do not recall a lot of really
negative publicity for you must heard
isn't that right there's been an ongoing
smear campaign yes
an ongoing negative publicity campaign
it's an orchestrated smear campaign
you have no evidence of that do you
misheard just look me up you'll see
let's take a look at some of that
okay
thank you everyone for your patience
so ms heard my last question to you was
that there was a lot of negative
publicity for you around the time that
mr waldman made these statements isn't
that correct
i believe that they were made
i mean i believe that the statements
kind of kept being attached to new
defamatory
you know um articles that were like
smear campaign sort of attack articles
is what it okay let's go through some of
the articles
that were out in the press
so
plaintiff's exhibit 1267.
i could just publish that just for the
witness that would be great thank you
this is an article published on february
2nd 2020
and the title is
justice for johnny depp trends after
amber heard admits to hitting actor in
audio clip do you see that i see that
and if we can go to
plaintiff's exhibit
1268.
this one was published on february 3rd
2020.
it reads the title amber heard admits to
hitting johnny depp in recording
that's when his lawyer leaked an edited
tape
miss heard
do you see the title
amber heard admits to hitting johnny
depp and recording do you see that i see
the title okay
we could please go to plaintiff's
exhibit 1269.
this one was published on march 17 2020.
amber heard slam door into johnny depp's
head reveals new audio do you see that
yeah these are more of the pr plants
let's go to 1270.
this one was published on march 31st
2020
amber heard to be sacked from jason
momoa's aquaman after johnny depp's
controversy reports
do you see that i
i don't go to plaintiff's exhibit 1271.
[Music]
you see the title that says johnny depp
says ex-wife amber heard sliced his
finger off and it quote erupted like the
vesuvius vesuvius
i just don't know when that was um
i've never seen that article
we can go to 1272.
this one was published on may 29 2020
and it says when amber heard confessed
to smashing a door into johnny depp's
head clocking him in the jaw do you see
that i see that
going to 12.75
this one was published on july 15 2020.
amber heard stole my sexual assault
story ex-aid tells libel trial do you
see that this was adam waldman as well
it doesn't say mr woldman it actually
says kate james also says she often
received abusive text messages from
johnny depp's ex-wife doesn't it i just
know because he threw down the article
that's heard isn't that what that mr
waldman through the newspaper afterwards
that's heard that's not my question
the question is sorry the title of the
article says amber heard stole my sexual
assault story x-aid tells libel trial
kate james also says
your honor she opened the door
by saying it was adam waldman i'll
sustain the objection next question okay
let's go to plaintiff's exhibit 1276.
amber heard admits to hitting [ __ ]
baby johnny depp and court audio do you
see that misheard that's correct okay
let's go to 1277.
published july 28 2020
amber heard's sister thought she was
going to kill johnny depp claims witness
do you see that misheard i see that
in 1278
published on july 28 2020
johnny depp was the victim of of abuser
amber heard london's high court told do
you see that
i do see that
okay thank you your honor all right
thank you go ahead and take our our
lunch recess then ladies jim we'll go
ahead and take our hour lunch recess at
this point do not discuss the case with
anybody and don't do any outside
research okay we'll see an hour
all right we'll come back at 1 35 then
is that fine all right thank you
uh
i think already yes sorry
um
uh
all right thank you you'll be seated all
right your next question
uh tom may i please have you put up uh
plaintiff's exhibit 881a
miss heard i'm going to ask you to take
a look at plankton's exhibit 881a
this is one of the articles containing
the counter claim statements by adam
waldman is that correct
i haven't seen the article yet okay why
don't we go to page 8 of this article
adam waldman depp's lawyer said
afterwards quote amber heard and her
friends in the media use fake sexual
violence allegations as both the sword
and shield depending on their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as a sword
inflicting them on the public and mr
death do you see that yes i do is that
one of the statements that you allege
are defamatory it's defamatory
that's correct
okay um can we please go to plaintiff's
exhibit 881b
and if we could go to page 10
and 11.
in exhibit plaintiff's exhibit 881-b
deaf's lawyer adam waldman said the
various discrepancies proved that
nothing herd and her friends said about
the events of may 21 2016 could be
considered credible quite simply this
was an ambush a hoax
they sat
mr depp up by calling the cops but the
first attempt didn't do the trick he
told the dailymail.com
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property so amber her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up got
their story straight under the direction
of a lawyer and publicist and then
placed a second call to 9-1-1
but even this didn't have oh apologize
you're fine
okay
the
okay and if we can please uh pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 881c
and go to page 11.
this is another article misheard where
you
argue that uh mr waldman's statements
are defamatory correct
i don't know if this is taken from that
article because i can't see the article
in full
it's page 11 of the article
and the statement reads
come on
we have reached the beginning of the end
of miss heard's abuse host against mr
depp is that correct
is that one of the defame what you claim
is one of the defamatory statements
sent by mr waldman
i believe so okay thank you
it's heard you're not aware of any
career opportunities that you lost as a
result of mr waldman's statements are
you
well it's kind of hard to point to the
jobs you're not offered right the gigs
you don't get you were not replacing
aquaman 2 were you
they released me from my contract
and i fought to stay in it and they kept
me in it i just don't know how much i'm
in actually live the final cut
and you testified yesterday that l'oreal
actually extended your contract in april
of 2020. is that correct
in part they extended it and held me
and you testified yesterday that l'oreal
extended your contract again in november
of 2021 correct
not exactly they extended it because it
couldn't use me or any of the materials
for me
and that extension was for 20 months
right
that's correct
mr you testified yesterday how mr
waldman's statements quote torture you
every day do you recall that testimony i
do
and then
and that you look at them every day
i look at the um
online attacks the media you can't avoid
it to be honest that those statements
are often attached to
i don't look at his statements every day
and you testified that you just want to
move on with your life right
i do very much want to move on with my
life
but you've gone out of your way to
engage with mr waldman on social media
haven't you
uh i have made a comment i believe once
i did not i would not characterize that
as engaging with him let's please pull
up plaintiff's exhibit one two six six
i
you freaked out your microphone
your
microphone i don't have this yet so i'm
asking for it's really given to me
before it's a photo i think it's just
this is your tweet right misheard that
is correct i'm going to move to admit
and publish this tweet
objective relevance
ejection i'm sorry
i'm sorry relevance all right overall
the objection 881c
in evidence
can we please have it published to the
jury
i'm sorry one two six six i apologize
thank you thank you your honor
this is from march 26 2021 right that's
what it looks like yes and this is after
he made the statement you claim the
statements you claim are defamatory
right mister
21 yes
it's heard you tweeted adam waldman
quote yes mr waldman i may be wearing
makeup on this occasion but on every
occasion you will still be short did i
read that right
yes
we can put this down
thank you
mister since your relationship with mr
depp ended you have completed your level
three sommelier training haven't you i
haven't completed it yet
i decided to
no i'm on level three
you also have had a baby right i have
and you enjoy being a mother
more than anything
still love to cook
i do
and you love to hike
i've taken a break on hiking for a
minute
you have friends right
i do have friends and you spend time
with those friends
occasionally when i can and you exercise
regularly every day you just filmed a
movie in march of 2022 isn't that right
yes the one i just shot in guatemala
that i spoke of earlier and you have um
you had a major role in a major film
that's scheduled to be released soon is
that correct aquaman two
as i said i don't know if i
will even be in the final cut or how
much i will be it was difficult to stay
in the movie
you struck mr depp multiple times during
your relationship didn't you misheard
there were many times i had to use my
body to defend myself and that included
swinging wherever i could if it meant i
could get away absolutely that meant
a difference between a sore face and a
broken nose
you bet i would that's your testimony
under earth that you never struck mr
depp as the initial aggressor
well if he was holding me against the
wall by my neck you know i might be the
first person to have been the the first
one to
slap
which happened in australia you know
when he was choking me but i wouldn't
say i was the initial aggressor in that
situation
you got physical with mr deb often
during your relationship didn't you
i had to defend myself as best i could
um didn't seem to make much of a
difference you just couldn't control
yourself could you misheard
i tried to defend myself when i could um
but i was after years of not defending
myself
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 356 and your honor portions of
the exhibit were entered into evidence
yesterday but we moved to admit the
entire recording
and i can confirm that there's no other
voices besides miss herds and mr depths
and i intend to play
um from 129 27 to 1307.
so i have 356a in evidence does any
objections of the entire 356 coming into
evidence if you make if i may okay just
for a moment i have to check on
something
which one
for now and we'll double check our notes
on that because there was one that had
something in that that
couldn't go and i just can't find my
notes on that we'll just call it 356b
for now that's fine thank you your honor
could you just give me the times again
yes of course one two nine 27
two one three zero zero seven all right
and i'm just told that we already have a
b so you have to 356c okay thank you
thank you your honor
[Music]
promise you
i'm not gonna go around divorce i will
not say divorce
unless it's it and then i hope you leave
me
i'm not going to kill me too i will
leave you
it's fair i can't do it you know and i
think honestly if we hold each other
accountable to that
it's fair
ms heard that's you and mr deb on that
recording correct that's correct and he
told mr deb quote i can't promise you
that i won't get physical end quote
correct that's correct he was accusing
me of instigating something in a
situation i explained yesterday
and you also told mr debt that sometimes
you get so mad you lose it correct
that's correct i also explained the
context of that fight yesterday
isn't that exactly what you told ben
king on your way back from australia
that you get so mad you lose it
absolutely not i know that that's what
ben king testified to but i never had
that conversation with ben king
we could please play anytime i'm sorry
um i checked and i have no objection to
the entirety of 356 coming to 356 in its
entirety will be in evidence all right
thank you
thank your honor we could please play
from what's now been admitted
plaintiff's exhibit 356 in its entirety
from 705 to 743
i'm not going to be invisible [ __ ]
altercation with you
then don't you [ __ ] hit me
last night you [ __ ]
what all the other times you split
come on you cannot act like that it's
about that we're on a plane i can't
split no and you hit back so don't act
like you don't [ __ ] participate i
pushed you
i'm not going to get into the details of
that fight you and i both know that you
split when there is no physical violence
and that you do it and meet like at the
very beginning of fights these days and
if you split and you go into a different
room you won't actually leave that house
it does nothing but perpetuate the fight
and you don't actually do it
respectfully don't
it's heard is that you and mr depp on
this recording yes it is
can we please uh pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 343
and i believe that one's been admitted
already into evidence yes ma'am
thank you and just for the record um
we're playing from two four six zero one
two two four seven two zero
i said to travis i said no i said to you
hey tell travis what just happened are
you telling me to do it you told me to
you said go do that
tell him what you're saying and i lied
that you punched me in the [ __ ] thing
you figured it out and you said no
[ __ ] i didn't what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and i watched you lie and then i didn't
punch you by the way you i'm sorry that
i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punished you know you've been a lot of
fights been around a long time i know
yeah when you [ __ ] have a closure you
didn't get punched you got hit i'm sorry
i hit you like this but i did not punch
you i did not [ __ ] deck you i [ __ ]
was hitting you i don't know what the
motion of my actual hand was but you're
fine i did not hurt you i did not punch
you i was hitting you how are you how
what am i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here bitching about it
am i you are that's the difference
between me and you you're a [ __ ] baby
because you started you are such a baby
girl the [ __ ] up johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
i had to [ __ ] out of there yes you did
so you did the right thing the big thing
the you know what you are admirable
that's you and mr depp on that recording
right mister that's correct and you said
you hit mr depp right
yeah i had to hit his body to get him
out of the door my question was you said
on that recording that you hit mr depp
right yes i did okay and you accused him
of being a baby for not wanting to be in
a physical fight with you right
incorrect i accused him of being a baby
for complaining about me
hitting him when he was trying to get
through the door i was trying to
barricade
right
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 368
and again your honor this is a recording
of just mr depp and miss heard um i'm
going to move for the entire exhibit to
be moved into evidence
all right any objection to 368
uh
i don't think so no your honor all right
no objection 368 in evidence in its
entirety
it's a shitty law
anyway
i opened the bathroom
door when you were knocking on it
after a few times i opened
and
you know you just commit you just kept
going you just kept going kept going
i tried to close the door three times
you know these keys just don't you know
and then wait and then
then i i
i accidentally i swear
when i was trying to close the door
i guess it scraped your toes
and i didn't i you know i didn't mean to
do that
and i bent down
and you either pushed or you kicked i
think you kicked the door
open i mean said caught the door
yeah more open
[Music]
i did not do anything different i did
not kick a door or push the door so that
it would hit you i did not i i swear it
lie i don't even that did not it was not
my intention i i think
i remember when the door scraped my toes
i
um
i reacted but this whole the door thing
i remember
i never did that that wasn't on purpose
i might have done it on accident okay
right so let's say that was an accident
and then stood up
i don't even know if i said i mean i
might have said like what the [ __ ] what
you know
whatever because i just been hitting the
head with the [ __ ] corner of the door
i'm so sorry i did not i'm sorry and
then i stood up
and then you [ __ ] clogged me
i i remember hating you as a response to
the door thing
and i'm really sorry about hitting you
with the door over or hitting your head
i did not mean to nor you didn't mean to
hit me in the head with the door but you
meant to i didn't punch me in the jaw i
meant to hit you and i
i did not do this thing with the door i
i do
i did mean to hate you so that you
didn't mean
the door no god no i didn't and but
punching me in the edge
i didn't okay i'm sorry i hate you i
didn't mean to hit you but it was in
response i just reacted in response to
my foot i just reacted and i'm sorry
it's below me your foot that was why you
punched me yeah
but
but i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry if i
dan that's you and mr depp on that
recording right that's correct and mr
depp was hiding from you in the bathroom
isn't that right miss herd
and mr deb said on that recording
i opened the bathroom door when you were
knocking on it does he he
i don't know if he said that and i i
didn't hear that and mr depp said when i
was trying to close the door i guess it
scraped your toes he says that doesn't
he correct and then you kicked the
bathroom door into his head didn't you
no i didn't and then you punched him
depending on yourself in that audio you
can hear it for yourself right and then
you punched him in the jaw i also did
not do that i tried to make that clear
on the audio tape too in futility so mr
depp said you meant to punch me in the
jaw right
are you asking me what he said on that
yeah on the recording yes he said that
and then you respond i meant to hit you
didn't you
as i explained yesterday i was trying to
get him off the door
and you said i remember i did mean to
hit you
meaning the door
the door was on my feet
i reacted instinctively to that you've
heard this audio before haven't you
misheard yeah we've already had this
trial before
yeah you've played it was played for you
when you were deposed in 2016 in
connection with your divorce from mr
depp wasn't it that's one of the times
i've heard it yes okay so you've had
plenty of time to think about how to
respond to this recording haven't you
i don't know what you mean by that well
let's take a look at how you responded
to it the first time can we please pull
up what will be marked plaintiff's
exhibit 1261.
the next thing that i'm going to play
with your honor
uh is hugh
this is another
new one
uh
i'm going to read it into the record and
i'll hand this to you so um
i will
so your honor for reference and i will
provide a copy of the deposition ms
heard's deposition and the divorce it's
uh page 372 lines
starting at line five through
seventy seven line twelve
all right i think
okay
can i approach yes
thank you
thank you
honor with permission may we please play
if we just get to that page make sure
everybody's at the
oh could you could you say the page
number again absolutely
page 372 lines five to
377 line
one is what i have twelve
on twelve
all right
if we could have a moment you're under
two read it before let's play
so
okay i i
i still don't think it's an impeachment
on her after reading it although rule
objection goes thank your honor if we
can please have it published to the jury
in the gallery
the next thing that i'm going to play to
you
uh is hugh would you listen to this
please
so
then they can
do a problem they can do it through
reading the deposition your honor they
don't need to do that
i ask them to take it off the screen
did you take it off the screen
okay that's fine thank you
i have no objection can we please start
it over
the next thing that i'm going to play to
you
uh as hugh
would you listen to this please
[Music]
[Music]
i
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so you told him in that
uh
excerpt that you
hit him with a door but did not intend
to hit him correct
did you say that
i i i said whatever i said in that
recording i don't um when you play it
for me it's hard for me to remember
everything and that's a recording marked
as exhibit the punching
uh queue it was absolutely cute would
you continue to listen to exhibit queue
are these from the same day
i i reacted but this whole the door
i'm so sorry
[Music]
i did not do this thing
so on the tape you tell johnny depp that
you did mean to hit him
and it also misrepresents
represents what that would actually
happen which is him trying to get into a
room i'm trying to keep him out of
and then he
runs the door over my toes trying to get
into the room i try to push him out of
it which is what the hit is referred to
and johnny whenever he was injured or
touched it always would refer to it in
these ways of punching
or clocked or whatever and whether you
didn't disjust it with him or not the
last thing you do in in talking to him
afterwards and trying to reconcile with
him is to get into what the definition
of those words mean to him
never i never even addressed it he would
if he was ever pushed it was it was a
close he called it a a cold clock i mean
it's just very dramatic isn't it true
you're smiling as that audio recording
is being played in your deposition
aren't you misheard not smiling because
of the audio i'm smiling because of
what's happening around me you even roll
your eyes at one point don't you
i was sitting opposite a whole table
full of lawyers who were snickering
laughing and rolling their eyes at me
while i was talking
is there something amusing about kicking
a door into your husband's head
no i was rolling my eyes and commenting
on what i was experiencing at that time
in recounting the story there's
something amusing to you about punching
your husband in the jaw
that is not what i was smiling about and
no i do not think it's amusing
ms heard you testified yesterday that
all you want to do is move on do you
remember that testimony
yes i do yeah your exact words were
quote i just want him to leave me alone
i want to move on with my life and he
won't let me do you remember that
yes that is correct
but that's not true is it miss heard
it is very true
you just haven't been able to move on
with your life have you
from mr depp
i'm here aren't i
in fact on october 11th
2018 you actually commenced an
arbitration action against mr deb for
defamation didn't you
i don't recall that no
your honor may i approach
may we approach
pull up plaintiff's exhibit
219. i misheard if you could please read
to yourself the first page of exhibit
219
all right
and if you can also read to yourself the
second page of exhibit 219
and if you can scroll down tom again
miss her just to
look at that page
and then scroll down to the next page
please
on the next page
does that refresh your recollection
misheard that you did in fact in october
of 2018 two months before you published
the op-ed in this case that's the
subject of this case you initiated an
arbitration against mr depp for
defamation
it's not my understanding i initiated an
arbitration i
it's my understanding that our lawyers
sent a lawyer i mean a letter to his
lawyers after he called me a liar again
effectively in an interview
and that's two months before your op-ed
that was published in december of 2018
right that is correct and that's six
months before mr debt filed a case this
case against you correct that's correct
so you fired the first shot not mr depp
i disagree we sent a letter
thank you
[Music]
it's hard isn't it true that you once
filled out a customs form falsely so
that you could get may we approach okay
i have the motion
mr you testified yesterday that when you
left the courthouse after obtaining the
domestic violence restraining order
against mr depp you walked out to quote
a sea of paparazzi and cameras right
that's correct you testified that you
were surprised to see the sea of cameras
that's correct
because it was quiet when you went into
the courthouse that morning
and the divorce had remained under the
radar up to that point you testified
that no one knew about your divorce so
you thought it was going to stay that
way right
no i always
figured it would come out i just
was trying to buy time
you knew the media had been alerted that
you were filing for divorce right
misheard no i just knew that it was
impossible to do that privately so you
could just hope it was a matter of time
you knew they were going to be there
didn't you no i did not
i mean i assume i assume since it's a
public building that there's that
likelihood or not likely a bit
possibility
but um
i was you know i was i was shocked
your publicist jody gottlieb was there
at the courthouse with you wasn't she
yes she was
so you anticipated that you might need
your publicist
i thought the filing might make um well
i was told the filing was public that it
would be impossible there's no way for
you to do a fi a private filing and then
the second that i filed for the tro
it would be public news i didn't expect
all these photographers and cameras to
show up at the courthouse in real time
but they did if we could please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 1280 which is a clip
from your divorce deposition and
you have at a page
i can alert you you have the transcript
there page 74 lines 22. you said 37
74 7
line
22. through 75 line 13.
i'm sorry just
72
74
line 22
through 75 line 13.
you're under my wheel okay
so
if we could please play
and display to the jury
playing to exhibit 1280.
did you send a text message to jerry
judge on may 24 2016
telling jerry judge quote i'm
desperately
trying to reach
johnny
it's extremely important
please tell him
i remember
sending the text message that is in
front of me right now to jerry
uh
and i would like
i remember sending this because i wanted
to tell johnny
or have him told by jerry or someone who
knew him or was close to him
basically i didn't want him to find out
online that i had or was about to file
or i had already filed for divorce i
wanted him to know verbally so i was
trying to reach him through a third
party
to tell him when i say reach i'm
specifically saying i would like him to
know information coming from me or
coming from jerry from me
so that he finds out about the divorce
filing
or my intention to do so
from some other source other than tmz
which was alerted
he slipped up there didn't you misheard
you let it slip out that tmz had been
alerted to your filing of the domestic
violence restraining order didn't you i
disagree that's not what i'm talking
about team z is the same outlet that you
released the video of mr depp attacking
the kitchen cabinets the day before this
deposition was taken wasn't it i didn't
do that i don't know how to do the
copyright to that video now doesn't it i
have no idea what tmz did they pay you
for that
i never got paid for it because i had
nothing to do with that so tmz was just
lucky in getting the inside scoop to
your divorce from mr depp huh
i have no idea it is not that's not my
area of
expertise i wouldn't even know how to do
that
and also what does that get me if i
wanted to leak things about johnny i
could have done that in a much more
successful way in a bigger way
for years now when you were extorting
him for seven million dollars i got a
fraction of what i was entitled to in
the state of california by the way what
extortion
tosavan reed is your ex-wife right
that's right she's mike's partner she's
the one that told
that you told this jury mr depp was
jealous of right
yeah well that was a 2013 fight
around march yes you testified that he
tried to burn one of her paintings right
that's correct you testified you tried
to burn
um
one of your favorite paintings that she
did right
i don't know if it was one of my
favorites
you committed domestic violence against
miss van ried during your relationship
didn't you
no i did not you assaulted her at a
seattle airport in 2009 didn't you no i
did not and people saw that
that's not true and it was covered in
the press
isn't that true it was a it was planted
in the press by johnny's team
two days after i got the tro
uh not coincidentally please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit one two seven
got nine may we approach
i could please have that article
displayed for the witness
this is an article from two years ago
correct misheard
i don't know when this may of 2020
that's not when it came out now
this story started getting planted after
i got a tro after i got a restraining
order against johnny
the headline says amber heard allegedly
struck
objection your honor i i think you're on
a rule she can't say that if you want to
approach again
the title reads amber heard allegedly
grabbed
struck her ex-girlfriend at the airport
doesn't it
yes and that's not true
may we approach
okay
so the article
the title is amber heard allegedly
struck her ex-girlfriend
thank you if i may start over
amber heard allegedly struck her
ex-girlfriend toss a van ree at the
airport in 2009. did i read that right
yes this is another example of the smear
campaign
so mr depp is not the only domestic
partner you've assaulted is he misheard
i've never assaulted mr deb or anyone
else that i've been romantically linked
to ever
no further questions your honor all
right cross-examination i mean i'm sorry
redirect
ms heard did ms van ray come out after
that article came in to make a public
statement it was false of course
objection your honor hearsay
your eyes should be at least overruled
thank you
of course she did
okay
now
let's talk about the tmz alerted explain
to the jury what you meant by the tmz
was alerted
so when you make these kind of filings
meaning divorce
marriage things like that they are
public record
and so when we filed for divorce when i
filed for divorce i asked my team to
file in the most discreet way
literally to put it under a stack of
papers and file it at the end of day so
kind of had more of a shot of being
missed by the paparazzi and by tmz and
those sorts of publicity
outlets i believe that we had been
remarkably lucky following the divorce
that it wasn't picked up and that it
gave me a precious few days
of of peace at that really fragile time
when i found out that they were
going to run the story or that they had
the information i was
trying to get a hold of johnny
to clarify
that i did not do this in a punitive way
i didn't want him to be mad at me i
didn't you know i didn't want him to
find out
in that sort of context online
and who had connections to tmz objection
calls for speculation
do you know i do know johnny spoke about
did mr depp tell you about who had
connections with mr with tmz yes we
talked about it his lawyer laura wasser
okay
now i'm going to start at the very
beginning here um you were asked by ms
vasquez about
why mr depp
won't or can't look you in the eye
and she read out or she played a tape in
which mr deb said you will not see my
eyes again do you recall that
i do and that was
during the mediation process in july
correct that objection leading first one
sustainable deleting when was this that
was in july of 2016 that was the first
mediation attempt we met after that and
johnny very much looked me in the eye
please tell the jury about the next
meeting after he said you will not see
my eyes again we met in the lawyer's
office they gave us
a moment
johnny kissed me again
held me
i cried he cried and then
we had a short exchange and he put a
note in my pocket that said i'll love
you dead or alive my slim
with his new phone number on it i'd like
to bring up michelle if you can
defendants exhibit 1581l
i'm sorry
do you recognize this
abstraction your honor
may we approach yes
could you tell the jury
what the coaster was that he slipped
into your pocket what it said
i said i love you forever my slam dead
or alive
and what if anything did it have an
edition
his new phone number
and
to be
just so we're clear
on how many occasions in that second
mediation
did mr depp
look you in the eye
many
okay
and when ms vasquez asked you
if you knew
why mr depp couldn't or wouldn't look
you in the eye here or in the uk
you said yes you know
why
please tell the jury why
because he's guilty
because he's he knows he's lying
otherwise why can't he look at
me i survived
i survived that man and i'm here and i'm
able to look at him
thank you
you were asked about a bruise that was
on your arm
from march 15
2013. do you recall how long before the
picture you had sustained that bruise i
do how long two weeks
you were asked
a number of times by ms vasquez
if you took pictures from
your incidents earlier in the
relationship
why didn't you
it was
something i started doing only kind of
incidentally you know i was commenting
to my best friend i was looking for
support from my mom things like that
i you know there was
a shame to say
never a thought that that this would
happen
i mean not until december
and my best friend taking pictures of me
to capture it did that even
that wasn't even a thing
it has been suggested by ms vaque
vasquez to you and your questions that
you didn't tell anyone about the abuse
until the tro is that true obstruction
honor leading
all right what if anything all right
who did you tell
about the abuse during the time it was
happening objection your honor bleeding
and hearsay is it sustained your honor
it's prior consistency it's leading it's
sustained next question okay
what if anything did you tell to anyone
about the abuse
hearsay i'll sustain your honor you're
honored i approach
misheard
how many
people have you
shared
the fact of abuse
prior to 2015.
objection your honor leading
calls for hearsay how many
overworld
roughly about ten
can you name them
objection your honor
hearsay
sh i think she can it's not offered it's
just to show that she had that she
informed people before they're suggested
your honor can we approach this is again
no you were asked
um
whether you had consulted a medical
doctor about any problems with your nose
correct that's correct and you indicated
that you in fact head after the divorce
objection leading
i i did did you did you or did you not
consult
uh a
e-ent after the divorce objection
leading
did you produce medical records to the
defendants relating to this objection
leading cause i'll sustain the objection
thank you next question
witness could be instructed not to
answer until i've already lodged my
objection for the objection please could
we bring up defendants exhibit 1077.
do you recognize this document
my my screen is black oh sorry
yes i do
and could you tell us what it is that's
the uh what my ent that year's nose and
throat doctor um told me
was objection your honor here all right
when there's objection please stop
talking thank you all right i'll sustain
the objection as to hearsay okay
uh
what if any you were asked if you had
it was suggested that you had not
produced this in discovery is that true
objection your honor leading you
[Music]
she absolutely did it it's leading is
its leading question though sustained
the objectionist leading
what if anything did you do to produce
medical records to the defendant to the
plaintiff in this case i turned over all
of my devices and they had a um the
johnny's team had a third party or
something they selected as a third party
go and pull all relevant documents from
those devices which i handed over do you
know how many were handed over
hundreds of thousands i believe maybe
maybe objection your honor lack of
foundation all right i'll sustain the
objection next question
and do you what if anything did you
produce to the plaintiff
in connection with your consultation
with an ent specialist relating to your
nose objection leading assistant
foundation hearsay
what if anything that is not the cure
all is sustained
when did you see an ent specialist
2017 or 2016 or 17
and
as a result of that consultation
what did you learn about
your nose objection your honor hearsay
i'm not asking her to tell what they
said
i'll sustain the objection
what if any production
did you make
to the plaintiffs
of your medical records with the ent
objection your honor lack of foundation
[Music]
okay if you only have foundation do you
know
whether
the records medical records uh from your
emt were produced in discovery objection
your honor lack of foundation calls for
speculation
i'm just i'm asking if she knows thank
you
yes okay
and
do you
do you recall
i'm trying i'm trying
um
what
if anything
did the medical records
reflect about your nose objection your
honor here say i'll sustain the
objection
do you have
injuries to your nose
yes
please describe those to the jury
i have um
i'm going to object to the extent it
calls for hearsay
and lack of foundation
and improper expert opinion
well
she can certainly testify too
we'll see where it goes go ahead okay
go ahead
i have a significant amount of scar
tissue in my nose objection your honor
i'll sustain the objection
what if any difficulty do you have
breathing objection leading
what if anything and that does cure
it doesn't but
all over world injection thank you
do you remember the question i have a
significant amount of trouble breathing
at night and i
i've been putting off having surgery for
it okay
now you were asked
about december 15 2015
and miss vasquez suggested that you did
not report the abuse of the injuries to
aaron faladi do you recall that
objection your honor leading yes
i'm entitled to go into what ms vasquez
is objection is leading i'll sustain the
objection okay
did you report
what if anything did you report to aaron
fellotti
about the abuse you sustained on 12 15
2015. objection leading and hearsay
did you tell nurse philadi on 12 16
2015
about the injuries you sustained
from the 12 15 2015 attack
i did i believe i sent her pictures too
okay
and did you text
with nurse pilate on 12 16
2015 about the injuries that you had
suffered as a result of mr depp's attack
on you on 12 15.
yes she guided me through a concussion
check
and did you tell
connell cowan
about the injuries you said obstruction
your honor hearsay
it's prior consistent statements
all right i'm going to sustain the
objective at this point next question
do you recall dr laurel anderson
testifying that she saw two black eyes
okay
what if anything do you recall from
laurel anderson's testimony
in this case about what she observed on
1217 2015.
objection your honor this is outside the
scope of cross-examination prior
consistency i'm going to sustain the
objective the observations for the 12-17
the same day
the objection
next question may me approach okay
when in december did you see dr laurel
anderson
objection lack of foundation
overall
i saw her two days after the attack
so on what day did you see her then um
that would have been the 17th of
december 2016. and i told her what
happened okay objection on or hearsay
i'll sustain the objection and when did
you
see dr connell cohen
i saw him the next day december 16th is
my best recollection
let's jump to east asia for a moment
and we saw a number of pictures from the
backless dress
what if any motivation would you have
to
claim that mr depp
was kneeling on your back knowing you
had a backless dress objection your
honor
bleeding
why
would why did you
say that mr depp was kneeling on your
back in east asia
in the closet of the hotel room in tokyo
i said that because it happened to me
and it would have been much more
convenient if i was making it up to not
include that detail knowing i had a
backless dress and i walked a press line
and got photographed
now
we've heard testimony about mr depp uh
making
a total of 65 million in 2015 and 2016
from his experts
objection your honor why leading
i haven't asked
i mean
why did you not ask for 32.5 million
from mr deb
your honor
leading
i said why did you not act irrelevant
how does it sustain the objection
objection to leading next question
why why can i just ask why did you not
ask for 32.5 million for mr down because
i don't know austin answered relevance
oh overruled good
because i didn't want it
i realized that that's what i was
entitled to but i didn't want it
that simple
the tape recording that was played that
has you laughing quite a bit
can you tell the jury what the context
of that particular tape recording was
i don't really
recall a whole lot about what was going
on i know we had been fighting kind of
ad nauseam and in this
sort of loop if you will and i'm doing
my best to
not show my pain that's what i
was trying to do
trying to be tough
not sure what kind of pain i was in
okay
now
ms vasquez asked you about how you got
your role in aquaman could you please
describe to the jury how you got your
role
in aquaman
i auditioned
not johnny i auditioned
i worked really hard and i went to
where we were filming the the first
movie justice league i went i think five
or five and a half months early before
filming commenced
when i heard that they wanted to fire me
and so i put myself in the jaw and your
honor hearsay sustain
keep it away worked really
i worked really
hard on that and had to prove myself
and i did that
for even though i was only filming for
six days i was there for six months
just worked my butt off that's why
what if any role did mr depp play and
you're getting aquaman
he tried to have me fired from it
objection your honor
speculation all right i'll sustain his
speculation how do you know that he
tried to have you for objection your
honor
calls for speculation and hearsay
foundation foundation i'm trying to
delay it foundation all right delay
foundation
i saw it i saw the emails i saw the text
how sustained objection is to hear say
next question
you were asked about isaac baruch and
why he and and that he saw no marks
what is your recollection of your
interaction with isaac baruch during the
week of may 22nd
i saw isaac when i was coming or going
meaning i was leaving or arriving to the
building i saw him at a distance we did
not have a
in-depth conversation nor would we
um
and i told him actually right after it
happened what his friend objection your
honor hearsay
i i don't think it's offered to prove
the truth of the matter to assert it
i'll sustain objection next question
okay
stay away from what was said can you
just tell us what what interaction you
had with him and and his opportunity to
observe you with absolutely no makeup
objection your honor leading sustain the
objection misleading
please describe for the jury your
interaction with isaac baruch during the
week of may 22nd
well not only did i have makeup on but i
i did attempt to kind of
let him know what happened
objection your honor hearsay
unsustained objection next question
you were asked some questions about
officer melissa science's testimony
what
if anything do you recall relating to
officer melissa signs testimony relating
to
your injuries objection your honor
hearsay your honor said i could redirect
after the cross-examination
[Music]
what if anything do you recall of
officer science's testimony in this case
relating to your injuries and the
property destruction
i recall her saying that she
didn't feel that
my
the state i was in
enough of an injury to her it wasn't
injury
seeming to her
okay
and what about the property damage
she claims she did not see any property
damage but i walked
with her over broken glass so i'm i
don't know why she's saying that okay
what if any interactions did you have
with alejandro romero during the week of
may 20
too
i spoke to him briefly rejection on
earth to the extent of calls for hearsay
overruled at this point you spoke to him
i just i spoke to him briefly in passing
as i was entering maybe when i was
exiting the building but always when i
was on my way out or in from being
outside meaning
makeup i had makeup on always
as i do
why did james why did james franco visit
you on the evening of 5 22 2016.
objection calls for speculation do you
know yes please tell us because he was
my friend and he lived next door quite
literally next door and i had frankly
exhausted my support network with my
usual friends and
was happy to welcome as much friendship
at that time as i could possibly get
now the video showed him laying his head
on your shoulder can you describe for
the jury what the interaction was
without saying what was said what the
interaction was that led to that
he
uh
after seeing my face
put his protection
calls for speculation that doesn't call
for speculation if she sees that he sees
he touched the side of my house
okay again your honor if we can instruct
the witness if you could wait till after
the objection please all right
what did mr franco do uh on the elevator
before laying his head on your shoulder
he i'm gonna touch the side of my face
and
responded to what he saw
we talked about the uh
you were shown a bunch of newspaper
headlines and there was one in
particular referring to sexual violence
what if anything did mr waldman do to
you
relating to that article objection your
honor
lack of foundation calls for speculation
what did he do to her
unintelligible i i don't understand the
question overall we'll see where it goes
uh he was carrying the paper that had
that headline on it that he leaked and
threw it
at me at the uk trial we were
unfortunately sat kind of
actually literally next to one another
with kovitz facing in between us and he
threw the paper down at me as he sat
down with that on the cover
and where was that
in the uk at the uk trial objection your
honor this is beyond the scope
that's not beyond this
thank you
why did you tweet about the makeup and
mr waldman because he was calling me a
liar and a hoaxer and that this was an
elaborate hoax just to get johnny
objection your honor hearsay
i'll sustain the objection next question
next question yeah okay um
i don't have any more questions you're
all right thank you all right maybe you
can have a seat next to your attorney
okay
you can you can go seat next to her
that's fine
all right ladies and gentlemen let's go
ahead and take our afternoon recess then
for 15 minutes to not discuss the case
with anybody and don't do the outside
research okay
all right is
is your next witness a live witness
remote witness or deposition
deposition all right so we'll get the tv
set up for that and let's just come back
then at 3 30 okay all right thank you
i
there is evidence
in the tweet i know that the
the uh the tweet plaintiffs three
um is a retweet or a tweet that has the
hyperlink of the um online op-ed
in it
and i know that a mere hyperlink without
more cannot constitute
uh republication however here
when there's additional content that
could constitute
uh republication in this matter so there
is evidence of ownership and additional
content uh that the jury could find
constitute republication and that is a
factual question that does survive a
motion to strike therefore the motion to
strike is denied as the council thank
you your honor all right thank you all
right are we ready for the jury
all right
do
um
foreign
all right thank you maybe steven are
your next witness
our next witness is mr io tillett wright
and it starts with counsel for mr depp
asking questions and then we'll switch
over to me all right thank you
uh good morning again
have you had any communications with
miss herd at all including texts or
emails or otherwise in connection with
your preparation for this definition
when's the last time you spoke to
her april of last year april or may
almost a year ago
mr wright
when did you first
meet mr
i met amber in
the end of 2011.
and where did you meet her
in los
angeles and what were the circumstances
of the meeting
a friend was introducing us to each
other
so that i could photograph her for a
large portrait series that i was doing
at the time what was your profession in
2011
i was a photographer and i worked for
the new york times i think
i don't
recall exactly everything but
in 2011 you were both a photographer and
separately worked for the new york times
as a freelancer i worked for the new
york times as a journalist
and photographer
and what was
what is your profession today
i'm a writer and a producer
and between 2011 and through the present
have you had any other professions other
than photographer writer or producer
yes and what are those
i've hosted
a television show or two
i
made some podcasts
i
wrote two other books
two books three books
three books i've written three books um
a number of things i don't know there
are more things
but i yeah i've always been a
multi-hyphenated person
to the best of my recollection
uh
we initially met at a mutual friend's
house which i think i already stated
that friend is also an actor
and
had met amber
at the children's hospital while they
were both volunteering
and
knew that amber had done quite a bit of
lgbt activism
and
mentioned my project to her and then
invited her over to
uh the other friend invited amber to her
house so that we could all meet and um
amber and i
[Music]
discovered that we liked the same books
and we liked
psychology and and just
you know laughed and had fun that night
and then i asked her if she would
participate in the photo project i think
or somebody did and she said yes
um
a couple of days later i went to the
house that she was staying at and i
photographed her
for the project
and then
thereafter i went back to new york where
i lived
and i remember her texting me and saying
that she was shooting a movie in new
york and did i want to get lunch um
so we got lunch and we
became friends
okay please walk me through that we met
in 2011
we started becoming friends
[Music]
soon thereafter
um
in 20
very early in 2013
um i came to l.a to spend a couple of
months with my then
i don't know if she was my girlfriend or
my fiance at that point but the person
that i was in a relationship with
um in a very serious relationship with
and
um during the time that i was in la i
spent more time with amber we both spent
more time with amber
and i was introduced to johnny
and uh
the summer
of 2013
i ended up
moving to la during which amber and
johnny and i got
even closer very very close
we remained close the three of us for
two-ish years
and then
all of this happened this nightmare and
uh
johnny and i stopped being friends and
amber and i stayed friends
um
and then amber and i were friends up
until the date that i told you that we
last smoked
and at some point in time did you live
on the same property as johnny depp in
amber heard
yes
and when was that
was august 2013 until
um
i believe june 1st of 2014 i moved into
my own house so nine months
and
[Music]
why is it that you
left that property left living there
because i didn't
want to live
for free in someone's property and i
wanted to have my own house and support
myself and for how long after that did
you
stay close
with both johnny and amber
i stayed close with both of them
i don't remember it it was a
sometime in
2015 i think
late 2015 maybe
johnny and i
were no longer
i think
the period when i
[Music]
really
stopped considering johnny a friend of
mine was december of 2015.
okay well let me ask you this way
um
you never saw mr depp assault or be
misheard on any occasion correct that's
correct
i just would like to clarify mr
president that's a question you already
asked me so you're asking me the same
question again about whether or not i
witnessed mr death assault misheard
that's right
no i have not witnessed that let me ask
it this way then have you ever
personally seen mr depp assault or beat
miss heard on any occasion
no
now back to this same paragraph
where it says
my experience of johnny during the time
that he that we were close from 2013
through 2015
was that he could be incredibly kind
generous and loyal
can you give me examples of his kindness
generosity and loyalty during that
period of time
johnny when sober was
lovely and magical and
very funny
um
johnny
when sober
was
incredibly lucid and um
imaginative and
i felt a
kindred connection with him and a shared
perspective on the world that i've
shared with very few people in my life
um
johnny
went sober understood
how much influence he had over people
and
he was very um
kind to them about it and generous with
talking to them about
whatever
came up and he was also one sober very
um
[Music]
you know he made time
for people's nervousness around him
which i witnessed on a number of
occasions
he also um
he had his his
number of houses on that street
and there was a constant
rotation of different people coming to
town
who could all afford to live somewhere
else or stay somewhere else
who
um he would let
and enjoyed having in those houses which
i find to be um generous
in the next paragraph paragraph six you
refer to
mr
depp's
struggles with respect to oxycontin you
say that in late 2013 after dental
surgery he became hooked on oxycontin
did you ever experience him while he was
on oxycontin
yes
and while he was on oxycodone did you
ever experience him to be mean or
vicious
i can't answer that with any accuracy
because i don't know
whether or not the times that i did see
him
because he was also on an octagon
in paragraph five where you say that
um
he could he could be incredibly mean and
vicious especially when he was drunk or
high when you refer to drunker high what
substances are you referring to
the substances that i saw him ingest
with my own eyes were cocaine and hard
liquor
marijuana
ecstasy
mushrooms
uh
wine
i
probably some other things those are the
immediate ones that jump to mind
um
cocaine and any kind of alcohol
would bring out a very very ugly side of
him
um
very misogynistic and cruel
and
other things and
um
when he would take
any kind of psychedelic like ecstasy or
or
mdma
he would become paranoid when he would
drink alcohol he would become paranoid
yeah i think that answered your question
[Music]
you mentioned that uh you witnessed him
having had cocaine did you ever have
cocaine with him
no
were there any drugs or
or substances that
you
took with him
i don't smoke marijuana i don't do
cocaine
for the entire period that i knew johnny
and there
after
i did not drink alcohol
there was a
i think
one week period
um during the peak of my breakup during
which johnny offered me
um some pain pills to get through
the intensity of that situation
um and that was the only time
that i took any substances
for three and a half years no that's not
true that was the only time that i took
any um
substances
with johnny
and
uh yeah
yeah all the other things that i had
stated
previously about what i do and don't do
are also accurate so i'm sorry just to
summarize that
it is your testimony that
um
[Music]
when you
witnessed
mr
drunken high
you were not also either drunk or high
is that your testimony my testimony is
that during the entire period that i
knew mr depp i was never drunk or
drinking or consuming alcohol at all
my testimony is that for a one maybe two
week possibly two and a half week i
don't remember period
um
on a
sporadic occasion
i took some pain pills that mr depp
offered me
for
to get through an extreme emotional pain
situation
um
when i witnessed johnny doing cocaine i
was not drunk or high
other
occasions that i witnessed johnny
drinking i was not drunk or high
there was a very narrow window during
which i was taking some non-uh
mind-altering
pain pills
for a very brief period during which i
witnessed johnny
drunken high
did you ever witness mr amber heard
drunk or high yes
and
did you ever witness her drink alcohol
yes did you ever witness her um
ingesting cocaine
are you are you asking like ever in the
history of time have i ever witnessed
amber
ingest cocaine that's the first question
yes
the answer is
no
amber was vehemently against britain
did you ever when does her
uh smoke marijuana
no
marijuana is in her hair
what is her drill i haven't spoken amber
in a year but as far as i know and have
known her for the last 11 or 12 years
amber doesn't have a narcotic
of choice
have you seen her in just ecstasy
yes i believe so
yes how many times have you seen her in
just texas
[Music]
i can think of one instance in
particular when she took it um
for her birthday like a celebration
uh
wasn't you recall what year that was i'm
an event
other than the uh
narcotics and alcohol
that i mentioned
did you ever witness miss bird
[Music]
are you asking me if
other than
what did you ask me about cocaine
ecstasy and mushrooms
i've witnessed amber taking any other
illegal narcotics or are you asking me
about prescription medications can you
clarify
narcotics other than prescription
narcotics
i don't know but i don't actually think
no
amber drinks red wine um
when she's not training or let me
rephrase that amber when i knew her
drank red wine
in the evenings uh
fairly regularly with the exception of
when she was training for
an acting role
have you ever witnessed uh mr sorry
misheard
intoxicated
yes
and
how often would you estimate that you
witnessed misheard intoxicated i don't
know how to quantify intoxicated if
you're asking me how often i witnessed
her drunk is that your question yes
amber's um
strangely immune to getting
drunk unless she's really drunk a lot so
i didn't see her drunk very often
i saw her
drinking often but i didn't see her
out of her faculties
very often
like
you know i saw that a handful of times
in the 11 years that i knew her
and how would you describe um
how alcohol affects miss herd's
personality based on your experience
you know it depends on the circumstance
if
it was during a moment when
she was celebrating
it would make her
loose like if we were salsa dancing then
you know she would
have fun and
be
fun and at a party and
you know
inebriated and dancing and having fun if
she was in a stressful situation
i think it would just kind of
exacerbate whatever the feeling of the
moment was
i'm going to
ask you to state your name for the
record nobody has yet
this is me
all right go ahead
bring up uh depth exhibit number one
again please
mr tillett wright you were asked some
questions
by mr presidio
and i'm going to take you back up to the
first page where you were asking
questions
um
and
he's he started out with i i'm just
going to draw draw your attention to
paragraph four and you indicated you met
johnny depp through amber
uh
and you hit it off immediately do you
see that
yes i do okay and then you explained
to mr presidio that you considered
johnny to be a close friend and you
cared very much about mr depp is that
correct
he became a close friend and i did care
very much about it i still care very
much about him all right could you
please describe
that
relationship that you had with mr depp
up until i think you said december of
2015
sure
um
okay mr depp and i
first met amber invited me over to his
house with my then
partner girlfriend i don't know if she
was my fiance yet or not um
and i think february
of 2013
right at the beginning of 2013.
um
and we all hung out the four of us hung
out in his house
um in his living room
and just kind of talked and got to know
each other
and it was sweet i was mostly hanging
out with amber and kind of meeting this
person it was a
trip to meet someone
like that you know and see his house and
he was
very friendly and very welcoming and
very kind
um
and then
the next time we saw each other
was at um
amber and i both like to do what we call
family dinners so we
invite people over and cook for them and
and have
a dinner party and um
amber
did an elaborate family dinner at her
house and johnny
and i and my ex and amber
and i believe whitney
were there i don't know if anyone else
was there i'm sure somebody other people
were there i don't remember um
and johnny and i
[Music]
really connected at that dinner we were
sitting either opposite each other or
just catty corner from each other and um
i left feeling
very intense connection to him and i was
like well yeah sure everybody probably
feels an intense connection and because
of who he is
i'll forget it it's ridiculous
and then a couple of days later
um
amber had another dinner
some such a dinner at her house
and
[Music]
uh johnny and i had another really good
time and and felt
very connected and really laughed a lot
and whatever and um
at the end of the dinner as i was
standing to leave with my
ex
johnny came up to me and said
um
i
i don't really know how to
say this
because it doesn't happen to me very
often but i think i love you
and i felt
strange because i felt the same way and
i said that's funny because i had that
same experience after the last dinner
party too
and then we joked about how crazy and
ridiculous that felt
um
and
we exchanged phone numbers
and
then he
he texted me wanting to talk about amber
a couple of times and i felt that it was
like
kind of violating her privacy
so i said that i was happy to be
friendly with him and happy to um
i don't remember exactly what i said but
something to the effect of like
you know i i'm happy to be to give
advice or to to help you guys
stay in concert with each other
but i don't
want to um violate anybody's
privacy with the other one and he i
think he really respected that and
really liked that because he also values
his privacy
greatly um
and then yeah i was in la for a couple
more months and i don't know i think
maybe we hung out more during that
period i'm not sure
um
i don't remember if they came to new
york during the next stretch of time or
what happened but um basically by the
summer
i came back to
l.a to write
and had a very bad breakup with that
fiance
and
was going through some things personally
that johnny um
you know he was like i recognize what's
happening for you
it was like particularly bad anxiety
related trauma related
things um
and he
i didn't expect him to offer me any
support around that stuff but he just
was like wait i see what you're going
through
um
you know this is my experience of it i
have the same thing and let's talk about
it and like
if you need anything i'm here and i was
like thank you so much you know i didn't
really expect that
um
and i went back to new york for
to be with my family for a couple days
or maybe a week or something and
it was very painful to be there and he
had said if it's painful to be there you
know just let me know and come back and
stay here and so i did
and i came back and i originally was
going to stay at amber's house
because she kept her apartment for a
number of years while they were together
even though she stayed at his house a
lot
um that she paid for etc and i she was
you know the person that i'd known
longer so i felt more comfortable being
in her house and then
the consensus was that i should be
closer to them
and so they said oh there's this house
that's just sitting empty at the end of
the street just stay there
i was very hesitant because i didn't
want to
take advantage of him
um
he was insistent and he was very kind
about it and and he said that he
understood
fully what having ptsd and anxiety could
do and that he wanted to help
um
so i i went and i stayed there and then
i was
i'm guessing in august of 2013 and then
in september i think amber went to
england to shoot a movie
um
so i was there
and johnny and i would hang out on our
own and johnny doesn't have
a ton of friends
um because he can't
and
i would go up and hang out with him you
know we really enjoyed each other we
really liked each other and so we would
just hang out you know on a daily basis
eat dinner or
watch movies and i'd hang out with his
kids and got you know very like into
like a very sweet uncle nice nephew
relationship with his kids and they
called me uncle io and um
mr tillet right
did you ever call mr deb brother or your
brother refer to him as your brother
yes i did
now
i'm gonna take you to paragraph five of
dev exhibit number one
and uh mr presidio asked you about this
paragraph as well
and at the end of it you had said and he
could be incredibly mean and vicious
especially when he was drunk or high
what did you mean by what i meant by
that
was
on a number of occasions
um
i saw you know amber or he i think also
would ask me
to come and help
he and i had more of a like
mano amano kind of relationship and
she and i had a
i i was kind of like the only person
that would check either of them
um
for a while
and so they would both ask me to do that
with each other
um so i saw him
for example i remember there was a time
when um
it was very late at night i was down the
hill
so i went up the hill and he was outside
by the pool with a glass of what i
understood to be whiskey and she was
inside crying
um
and very upset in the kitchen i think
and then i went outside
and talked to him for a long time um
situations like that or
um
and he would say things he said
something to me that night that i i
thought that night by the pool where i
thought
jesus christ you know
things like
she's gonna
you know all she's got is her looks and
you know she has no talent and when her
tits start to sag
and her face gets wrinkly nobody is
going to be
interested in her
for anything and she's so she
you know better
like
to figure out another way to survive and
[ __ ] like that sorry part of me things
like that and um
i
[Music]
also witnessed him um
when amber was in england
marilyn manson and paul bettany came
over at one point and there was
a great deal of cocaine and alcohol
involved
that i witnessed them doing together
i don't
specifically recall if mr bettany did or
did not partake in the cocaine
or really much of anything except things
that he said and his personality but um
mr manson and
mr depp
are took in a lot of cocaine what if
anything
did mr depp tell you about
his struggles with drugs and alcohol and
um
we sat on the couch and he told me a
number of things he told me about his
childhood he told me about growing up in
kentucky told me about growing up very
poor and how his mom
was verbally and physically abusive
he told me that when he was very very
young like 13 or something he started
drinking and taking drugs i think or at
least drinking quite heavily he was even
kind of like
yeah it's crazy i know but i've been
doing it my whole life and built like a
tank and so that was kind of the nature
of the conversation um
and he told me that he had
struggled with
ever not drinking or ever not doing
drugs and he also told me that he didn't
particularly enjoy
being sober um
but that you know
people around him were very concerned
he was very very um
concerned with his children
and he would express
shame or regret about times that he had
been
inebriated to the point of falling down
or
embarrassing himself you know
urinating on himself things like that
when his children were around and that
he was very grateful to the people who
had kind of
shielded them and whisked them away
[Music]
and he
told me that um
in his relationships with
previous women
uh his drug and alcohol
use had been an issue
um
but that he just didn't really like life
sober and that it was too painful to be
alive without
imbibing or getting high and
he also told me that he
had experienced
great bouts of jealousy
in relationships that had that it also
led to a lot of drinking and a lot of
um
rage activities
um he told me that that happened with
winona he told me that that happened
with
um
kate
and sorry winona ryder and kate moss he
told me that that had happened with
vanessa parody
mr tillett wright um
what if any observations did you make
about
mr depp abusing oxycontin
over the course of those two years
mr depp told me verbatim
that he was addicted to oxycontin
um and i have a text message from him
where he's expresses that
it's extraordinarily hard to kick and
that it um
i don't remember exactly the words that
he uses but he he he referred to it to
me verbally
many times as like the hardest thing
that he's ever tried
to kick
which he's tried to kick most things he
said it was harder than heroin
um
so he he was very um
open and verbose about
oxycontin having gotten addicted to
oxycontin
so
what if any observations did you make
about mr deb
smoking cigarettes and
joints
marijuana
mr depp
as far as i could see
always had a cigarette or joint
in his mouth at all times
to the point where i was confused about
how he could function
he also showed me his
marijuana closet that had
i don't know
tens and tens of pounds of
wheat in it
what if any observations did you make
while you were staying at sweets here i
think you said that was august 2013
through may of 2014 with respect to
the type of alcohol and the amount of
alcohol that mr depp was consuming
when i saw mr depp drink
um
it was
often hard liquor
i believe it was whiskey
and
gin and tequila maybe
um it could also be vodka i don't know
he had a full bar in his in 80 the house
that they
with his recording studio in it that
they mostly stayed in so
um
i know whiskey for sure and there was
also red wine
a lot of red wine
and when you
talk about the whiskey and the red wine
how much did you observe mr depp
consume on any given occasion of those
i don't know
the one occasion i know specifically was
the one that i mentioned before during
the argument where he suddenly had a
glass of whiskey and i remember it being
like
i remember clock because i grew up
counting people's drinks
i remember clocking that it was a very
large pour
in the glass of whiskey
if you recall those i i think my
question was you know what if any
observations did you make or did mr depp
ever tell you about him blacking out mr
deb
was very open with
everyone that he
was a heavy user
and um
he told me about i know there was one
instance where he had this very large
house property
so if sweets or avenue goes like this
um
the house that i was staying at 76 is
down here then there's 78 which is right
here and then up here is 80 and then
across the street i guess is 82 and 82
is a very large compound so he and i
were staying i was at 76 or up at 80 and
then 82 they lived in for a brief period
of time
um
and he told me about
like vanishing into 82 into the like
the property into the like because it
was very lush and very a lot of trees um
and went up quite far up the hill and he
told me about kind of like blacking out
and going in
there
on one instance
um
[Music]
he told me
i know that he told me that in
australia
he had blacked out
um
but he also told me that he [ __ ] up so
i don't
in terms of specific blackouts
there were a number
i think he said on the plane
he said that he didn't remember what had
happened
what if anything
did mr depp say to you
about whether
he
wanted to become sober and clean
mr deb um
[Music]
expressed to me that he wanted to get
sober for amber
that he didn't enjoy being sober
um
it wasn't fun
and that
it was distressing and exhausting
um
and very hard to do
he didn't he really really um resented
having to be sober
um
yeah
he didn't want to be
and what if anything did mr depp say to
you about
his perception of
amber's role in him
becoming sober and clean
he expressed a number of times that he
felt like she was his leash
and she was holding him back from doing
what he wanted to do in terms of
substances and alcohol
oh i just want to go back to another
incident that i remember he told me he
blacked out was on on the island he went
to the bahamas there were two different
instances
one
was
um i guess like they had only recently
met
and he told me that he
passed out face down in the sand while
his kids were there
and that um
the staff had like whisked his kids away
so that they didn't see it mr tiller
right
when you said that mr depp
uh
used the term monster what do you recall
him saying about that
and the language that ended up being
kind of settled on
was that
there was
a side of him that was
the monster
and that it was not who he was
but it was something that lived within
him that he had to battle
and the language that he always used was
that of
um
battle and battling
battling the demon battling the monster
so that
the monster you know he would say things
like the monster will not win
um
i will not be that type of man you know
i i don't want to i don't want to be
that type of
man or husband i don't want to hurt
uh he would call her slim i our slim
our girl
referring to all of her friends and him
and her and i
yeah
what if any observations did you make of
mr deb both in terms of physical
as well as temperament
when you perceived him as having too
much to drink
mr depp would
drink
and or take drugs
he would
get
very mean
very surly
very uh
paranoid extremely paranoid
he would weave these elaborate
situations in which
amber was having affairs with every man
that she ever worked with and every
woman she ever came in contact with
um
he became very demeaning johnny is
incredibly intelligent incredibly smart
and witty
and he would point his jokes at
people
um
amber's appearance her talent
her lack of talent as he perceived it
um
why he thought that she was actually
famous which he always implied was just
because of her looks
um
and because he thought that everyone
wanted to have sex with her
and he would
insult his fans
he called them i remember he called them
remoras which is the type of
[Music]
sucker fish that attaches itself to the
hull of the ship and puts a hole in it
and then sinks it
um
he would
rail against his mother and his sister
um
sisters
pretty much you know
anyone that he felt had crossed him or
could cross him
um
he became very nasty about what if
anything do you recall mr depp saying
about
his mother and comparing his mother
to amber
mr deb
told me
that
his mom was viciously cruel to him
during his upbringing
and that she was
also viciously
like violent
um with him
and with his siblings and with his
father
um he referred to her
pardon my language as a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ]
lot
and
he
seemed to
kind of compare them in the sense that
he
was he said at one point um
something to the effect that's right
here actually
uh yeah i already have a mom it was a
[ __ ] to me i don't need another one in
my life
there was a fair bit of that kind of
like
you know my mom's been awful enough to
me already i don't need another woman
who's gonna
also
be awful to me
what if any discussions did you have
with
johnny
about the fights he had with amber
we had a lot of discussions about his
fights with amber
um
what do you recall
in the very beginning
he expressed that
she made him feel crazy that he was so
in love that it made him feel crazy
the very first time
that i mentioned september of 2013
when he and i were
alone together a lot he expressed that
he thought that she was cheating on him
and sleeping with her co-stars
in england on the films and i said to
him on the film and i said
listen
you know
i know her i think pretty well
and i talk to her a lot and i think i
think if she was having an affair i
would be one of the very few people that
she would tell about it
and
i don't hold secrets or lies for anybody
and i would i would tell you if that was
happening so you could make your own
decisions but um
as far as i know that's really not the
case and i think that she's really in
love with you and i think that she also
is worried that you are having affairs
because both of you are used to being
sex symbols
on earth
and
both of you
need to just accept the fact that you're
really in love with each other and
lean in and be together and love each
other
um and he told me that sometimes his
jealousy would make him
um
[Music]
fiddle
crazy and outside himself
and that
he had to get it under control
um
and that it would cause them to fight
to be specific in regard to your
question
um
he told me about the fight that they had
the time that i went up there
are you asking for specific instances
are you asking about the nature of their
fights no i yeah i am asking for what he
told you about their fights and specific
instances yes
so to continue
with what i was saying from before
he told me about the fight um
in the middle of the night uh
when i was living down the hill at sweet
sur when i mentioned that i saw him with
a heavy pour of whiskey
i went outside to the pool and spoke to
him
um
and he told me about the argument that
they had had and that
she gets mean during fights
and that it really hurts his feelings
and that he then lashes out
at her
um
and then you know she called him old
and he then calls her
soon to be ugly
um and talentless and that they get
really ugly with each other
um
he told me
about a fight that they had um we went
to england
that september
um
it was whitney's
birthday i think
and her sister whitney um
and amber was stuck working my birthday
racquel's birthday and whitney's
birthday the three people who she was
closest to
um all have birthdays in september
it raquel's
just before the end of august whatever
we're all virgos and
um she couldn't be with any of us on our
birthday so we all went to england to
surprise her
and during that trip johnny proposed to
her
um
and they then
i'm pretty sure that night after the
proposal got in a huge fight
um
which he all they both told me about
separately
um
and he said i'm pretty sure that he
trashed the hotel room
let's see
i spoke to him
after
i went and talked to him after their
their fight on the plane
um
so
that's the that's the boston l.a plane
incident is that right that's correct so
mr telling wright i'm going to ask you
about
the boston la flight
uh incident you talked about it a little
bit earlier and you just said now that
you spoke with mr depp about it is that
correct that's correct okay
what do you recall
of your discussion with mr depp about
the boston
plane incident that happened in may of
2014.
and i went upstairs to his bedroom which
was like blacked out um and i i woke him
up i remember shaking his shoulder
and saying to him hey buddy like wake up
which was not something that a lot of
people did to johnny wake him from his
slumber
um
and he woke up and
we had a conversation about what
happened on the plane you didn't
remember being on the plane he didn't
really remember
getting off the plane
um
he didn't really remember much detail of
anything and he swore up and down
that he was going to stop and he was
going to stop drinking and taking drugs
and he was going to never do it again
that was that incident what if any uh
meetings related to alcohol
did you and amber attend in this time
frame
i i understand because we didn't go to
many meetings um
we
i took amber with me to
um al-anon which is a
it's like a sister program to aa
for the family and friends and loved
ones of addicts and alcoholics which i
regularly attended
so she came with me to a number of
al-anon meetings and she also had
i think one or two phone calls with my
dad's wife about how
she dealt with helping him
um
get off of
his drugs and and drink less and um
she read a number of books about it she
was watching documentaries about it she
would listen to any radio show she could
get on like anything anything she could
get her hands on that would give her
some tools for how to deal with this she
consumed in that period what if any
communications did did johnny have with
you in this time frame
about
wanting to
get back with amber after the boston
plane incident
we went to new york
and
i remember we were staying at the ace
hotel in midtown
um
and
johnny started reaching out to me he he
went eventually back to boston to start
filming again
it would have been in like the next day
or two because we weren't there for that
long
and
um
he reached out to me
and basically said to the something to
the effect of like
you know
i have to fix this i
will do anything that i can
and then uh while he was in boston he
let me know
and i think he was trying to reach amber
too but she didn't she wasn't ready to
talk to him um he let me know that he
had um engaged dr kipper and that he
intended
with every fiber in his being
to get sober and that
the nature of the conversation at that
point was that he he was going to beat
this thing you know please describe for
me
what transpired what what you discussed
with
johnny and amber relating to australia
in 2015. after
they were because they were married in
february and they went to australia in
the spring um
you know can i i'm going to interrupt
you just for a moment and forgive me i
just want to keep it chronologically
there um
you you described earlier that you were
present for the wedding correct in
february of 2015
yes okay
uh and you also had discussed uh about
amber wanting johnny to be sober for the
wedding
what if any observations did you make
about
johnny uh at the ceremony and with
respect to whether he was sober and
clean
you know
i don't actually know
whether johnny was i don't think johnny
was
drinking
on the day of their wedding i really
don't actually think he was
let me rephrase that before the ceremony
on the day of their wedding because i
was
going back and forth between their
um respective like private preparation
quarters where they were getting ready
because i was technically her best man
and his son jack was his best man
but i wasn't
one of the girls and
felt more comfortable over there with
them
but i was helping all the girls so i was
running back and forth on this golf cart
between i was also taking
pictures i was one of two people who was
friends with them that had worked as a
photographer so i volunteered to take
pictures so i was um
very intimately with johnny and jack
leading up to the wedding and he wasn't
drinking i don't think i don't i don't
remember seeing him drinking
then let me ask you this
after the ceremony as you were walking
to the reception what if anything did
johnny depp say to you
about amber
as we were walking back from the
ceremony
um we were coming into
cafe los camrones
which was where the party was happening
and i was walking with johnny
and congratulating him that they pulled
it off and that they they did it you
know
and he said
um
we're married now i can punch her in the
face and nobody can do anything about it
so i'm going to now turn your direction
to australia
roughly a month later after the wedding
um
you were you weren't present in
australia with amber and johnny correct
that's correct i'm showing you what has
been marked as exhibit number three do
you recognize anybody in this picture
i do yeah myself and miss heard
i do yeah please describe what you see
i see a number of long thin cuts
and
what if any similarity are those to the
ones you just described
having seen after amber returned from
australia
very similar
all right and are they the same were
they different ones i would have no way
of knowing if they're the same or
different ones but they're
similarly long skinny cuts like the ones
that i saw after she came back from
australia
i'm going to show mr tiller right i'm
going to show you what has been marked
as exhibit number five
um and it's a text message exchange
do you recognize uh
this text message number here below
arrows arc that's my old phone number
yes okay so
so is this does this represent the text
message exchange between you and amber
heard on 12 16 2015
yes it does okay and i'm going to start
you at the top
with the blue
it says i need you
do you recognize who
is sending that message
yeah mr tiller i'm going to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
exhibit number six
do you recognize the person in this
photo yes i do
please describe what you see in this
picture
i see
uh amber heard
and i see
an injury to amber's scalp
okay
and
what if anything do you recall
about
seeing anything similar to that when you
arrived in december 2015
at amber's penthouse i remember this
being one of the injuries that i was
shown when i arrived at
penthouse 3 of the eastern building on
december 16 2016.
and
does this picture that's marked as
exhibit number six accurately depict the
what you recall
seeing i remember this being one of
um
i think maybe two scalp injuries that
there were i remember there was another
one as well but i could be mistaken i
believe there was another one on a
different part of her head as well
do you recognize
uh
the picture that is set forth as
exhibit number seven
yes i do please describe for me
what what is depicted in this picture
that you recognize
this was a picture of amber's scalp
and does it accurate does this
accurately
depict what you saw
when you were shown it
as you testified earlier in december
2015
yes it does mr tiller i'm going to show
you what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number eight
uh
do you recognize this picture
yes i do please describe what's expected
there this is amber hurt's face
with a very swollen lip and does this
accurately depict
what you observed when you arrived at
amber heard's penthouse in december
2015.
yes
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number nine
do you recognize this picture yes i do
please describe
this is the clump of hair that i was
shown i believe when i arrived at
penthouse 3 on the night of december 16
2015. and does this accurately and
genuinely depict the scene that you
recall seeing
yes it does
thank you
now
did
what if any plans was there
as of december 1617 of 2015
for
amber to be
spending christmas with mr depp and his
kids do you recall
taking the pictures down while we talked
yes i do recall um
there was a plan for
um johnny and amber and lily rose and
jack and
uh raquel and her boyfriend or fiance at
the time josh
um
to go to the bahamas oh and raquel's mom
and
amber's parents
to go to the bahamas
and spend christmas on the island
together
um
yeah
mr tiller right i'm going to ask you
what if any conversations did you have
with johnny depp
about the december 15 incident i don't
think that
he and i i don't know that he and i had
a direct conversation about it i'm not
sure
if he and i had it direct
so what if any
i'm going to show you mr tiller right
what has been marked is deposition
exhibit number 16. it's a text message
exchange dated 210 2016.
do you recognize this document yes i do
it's a text exchange between me and
amber heard about a video that she sent
me
okay
now it starts out hi uh steve left me a
voicemail at 5am
uh
and that's from you correct
that's correct
do you remember what the voicemail
message was
yeah
yeah um johnny called me at five in the
morning and left me a voicemail in the
character of um some kind of management
of like a property manager um and he
said something about yes hello this is
management and um
i don't remember what he said but it was
something to do with like
we have a situation that we need to
change out to something and it was just
a lengthy
just off the wall nut bag ramble
in the character of
management mr tillerite i'm going to
show you what has been marked as exhibit
number 17 and then alex i'm going to ask
you to play this
[Music]
what happened
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
[Music]
were you in here
no so nothing happened to you this
morning yeah you're right i just woke up
and you were so sweet and nice
[Music]
we were not even fighting this morning
all i did was say sorry did something
happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
no that's the thing you want to see
crazy i'll give you a [ __ ] person
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this morning oh you got this guy
we got this going
oh really
really
sneak that [ __ ] on me
[ __ ]
thank you alex you can take this down
mr tiller wright do you recognize that
video
yes i do
was that the video that amber sent to
you on the text message exchange on
february 10 2016.
yes do you recall watching that video
on february 10 2016
yes i recall watching that video at the
time that i received those text messages
so i'm going to take you to 21 may 2016.
what do you recall
with respect to
a telephone call you received from amber
sure
um i was in new york um
i was there visiting family
um
i was in green point brooklyn
i was walking down manhattan avenue
and
i got i believe a text message from
amber that said something to the effect
of like can you talk and so i called
and i was walking down the street as
this happened
um she put me on speakerphone
so i was talking to both of them he just
stopped by to pick up some of his stuff
and he has a theory that he
um
either he wants to ask you about her and
i said okay
sure
hello johnny like you know
and
he i think it was he said or she said
um
johnny thinks that
you and i together
defecated on his pillow
i think the words were used were
um
[ __ ] on his pillow
so i started laughing
and i just i
i was laughing she was laughing
and when i realized that he was serious
i was like okay
look you know first of all
i wasn't there that day and so he got
very agitated by the fact that she and i
thought it was funny and he started to
get
um
more and more agitated and i could hear
him walk away
from the phone
he came clomping back down the stairs i
heard like uh
noise and then the phone dropped
and
um
he said to her
oh
you think i hit you
you think i [ __ ] hit you
what if i peel your [ __ ] hair back
and then i heard the phone drop again
and then i heard her scream
i remember her screaming
and i hung up the phone
and i called raquel immediately because
i know that she
lives one door away and would her and
her boyfriend josh who's a big dude
would be able to get there the fastest
and
i i called or texted her right away and
i hung up with her and immediately
called 9-1-1
in new york
and then i called
a friend of mine
in la who i knew had met amber a number
of times and
i think
i may have placed a second call to nypd
now i'm all frazzled and i don't
remember but i think i called nypd mr
waldman made some statements in april
and june of 2020
that
that
quote amber heard and her friends in the
media used fake sexual violence
allegations as both a sword and shield
depending on their needs they've
selected some for sexual violence hoax
facts as the sword inflicting them on
the public and mr deb that was made on
april 8
2020. what if any impact did that have
on amber based on your observations
amber retreated amber became
isolated
[Music]
embattled
extraordinarily uh distressed and then
on june 24 2020
walderman
accused amber heard of committing a
quote abuse hoax
against deb
what were your observations of how this
impacted him
i think that my previous statement
encompassed
that
during the time that you were friends
with johnny and you were speaking with
them up until the test you testified
december of 2015
what if anything did johnny depp ever
tell you
about amber heard being physically
violent to him
nothing ever at any point do you agree
with me that uh
mr depp and miss heard
uh
had many verbal arguments
yes i do
and you were witness to a lot of those
verbal arguments correct
i was witnessing some horrible arguments
okay
and
did you ever
hear
miss heard say anything mean to
mr depp in those arguments
yes
and did you ever hear ms heard
anything vicious
to mr depp in those arguments yes
so would you agree with me that
when they argued they were mean and
vicious to one another
in what they said
i would categorize it very differently
sir
well you testified that you heard ms
heard say mean ambitious things to mr
deb
when they argued
and vice versa is that accurate
yes
and although you witnessed
arguments verbal arguments between the
two of them where they exchanged mean
and vicious statements
you never saw mr death assault or beat
misheard on any occasion correct
no i never saw either of them but
physically
[Music]
did you ever
experience him become violent as a
result of or because of smoking
cigarettes or joints as i've already
explained to you
probably eight times i've never seen mr
depp
become physically violent with misheard
so if that's what you're asking me if he
smoked a cigarette and that made him
violent i think you know that that's
ridiculous and the answer is again no
did you ever witness mr
death become violent in any manner
on account of him smoking cigarettes or
joints if you want my honest answer my
honest answer is that mr deb mixed
substances constantly and i keep trying
to tell you that he mixed all kinds of
things together when he got crazy and
violent
so and upset and paranoid so and i never
knew what he had taken
when you say when you say when he got
violent when did you see him get violent
i saw i saw mr deb throw glasses and
dishware on
at least two occasions which i would
characterize as physically violent and
do i know if he'd smoked marijuana or
cigarettes before that i don't know
when were those two occasions
sometime during the time that i was
living in sweden
and and one sets at the eastern building
and prior to
throwing those dishes did you witness
him
by being any drugs or alcohol
i couldn't tell you but seeing as mr
depp always was smoking cigarettes and
marijuana my assumption would be yes
okay
do you recall
when miss bredenhoff
showed you a picture of a clump of hair
on the floor
yes
when you saw that
that was
more than a day after
um
it was allegedly pulled from her head by
mr death is that right
well if you want to get technical
my understanding was that their fight
happened uh very late at night
uh
which is technically the morning of the
16th
and i arrived at her house around
midnight the night of the 16th so
technically it's not more than a day
after it's in the same 24-hour period so
technically the answer to your question
is no
okay
so
i'm just talking about the hair on the
ground that you saw when you saw it was
it your understanding that it had been
there for more than 20 hours
i have no idea what time their fight
started or ended so i don't know if it
was 20 hours or 16 hours or 13 hours
but
my understanding again was that they had
gotten into a fight sometime in the
morning of the 16th
slash late at night on the 15th i don't
know at what point during the witch that
during that fight in which the clump of
hair was ripped out of her head
but it happened sometime
then and there so yeah sure my my
understanding was that that clump of
hair
had not been moved since it was ripped
out of her head
all right it completes
all right what's your next who's your
next witness we we have another uh video
deposition raquel pennington
it's a long one so we could listen to
some of it all right let's
start
we're going to start it today
at least get 30 minutes in
that's fine yeah all right and your
honor just for your benefit the jury's
benefit the questioning
starts with miss vasquez on behalf of mr
death and then i question miss
pennington at some point which will
probably be tomorrow okay thank you
thank you
can i please have you state your name
for the record
what city and state do you currently
reside
los angeles california
you've been deposed before right
yes
and you were to post in this first
divorce proceeding for mr duff is that
correct
yes
have you been deposed in any other
matter
no
what was the purpose of the declaration
that you submitted during mr death and
miss heard's divorce
the purpose of the
thing that i wrote which i don't know if
it was technically called a declaration
or
whatever it was it was to
write down
my account of events
as fresh in my memory as
possible
and miss heard asked you just to write
down
your witness account is that correct
i i do not remember actually i think
i don't know
did mr depp ask you to write down
anything in support of
any legal filings
i i i don't remember
so it's your testimony sitting here
today that you don't remember one way or
another whether it was mr depp or miss
miss heard that asked you to write down
your witness account
during their divorce is that correct um
i wrote down my account
that is the memory that i have i wrote
down everything as clearly as i could
remember it as soon as i could
you provided a witness statement in the
uk
proceedings is that correct
i believe so
do you recall how many
witness statements
you provided
just one
and you provided this witness statement
to the sun's attorneys
i don't
know who it got provided to
did you testify in the uk trial
um
[Music]
yes
and for which party did you testify for
the uk trial
i believe it was the um
publication
and by the publication you mean the sun
yes
when was the last time you spoke to my
turd
[Music]
perhaps
six months ago maybe more
what did you and mr speak about
probably um
it was before her baby was born
so we were mostly speaking about her
baby at that point
did you speak to
when was the last time you spoke to miss
whitney
heard
um
around
november
october november of last year
and when you say last year you mean 2021
yes
when did you first meet miss amber heard
um
i believe it was 2003
when you met matured in 2003 you
developed a friendship is that right
yes
would you say you were best friend
um we became very close friends
your friendship was matured it persisted
through her relationship with mr depp is
that correct
yes
and you were friends with ms heard
through her divorce from mr death as
well is that correct
yes other than when you lived at the
eastern columbia building which we'll
get to did you ever live with miss heard
yes
when was this
2017
2017 to 2018
yeah
where did you both live
we lived on holly drive
was that a home
yes
and did you pay rent
um
no
didn't miss herd
yes
sitting here today do you still concern
has hurt a friend
i wouldn't consider her not a friend
what does that mean
we don't speak
we are not enemies
why don't you speak
we grew apart
from my question right back yes
sitting here today you can't give me one
reason why you grew apart from misheard
i
wanted to
spend more time with other people in my
life and prioritize
other relationships and other
other relationships
over the course your friendship with
amber heard
did you ever see her using a lip dress
can you define illicit
drugs
not prescribed
um
yes
did you ever see her use cocaine
yes
how many times
[Music]
i don't know
outlet
no
less than 10
yes
less than five
yes
if you remember when was the first time
you ever saw amber heard use cocaine
i i don't remember
did you ever do cocaine with miss heard
amber heard
um
yes
how often
[Music]
not often was there a point in your
relationship with
using more cocaine
uh no
did you ever see ms amber heard use
cocaine while she was in a relationship
with mr duff
[Music]
oh no i don't think so no
you know what provisional is
yes
are you aware that miss amber hurt has
taken a drug called provision
yes
you know when she started taking it
no
do you know whether amber heard
continued to take provisional during her
relationship with mr death
no
did she ever tell you that she had
stopped taking provision
she never told me
that are you familiar with any of the
side effects of her visuals
no
didn't miss her ever tell you that she
was experiencing any side effects as a
result of providing
she never said anything
about that
you testified you saw misheard use
mushrooms
less than five times yes yes
each of those five times or less than
what's in a relationship with mr depp
did you say each of the five times
right
not each of the five times
how many times that you observed amber
heard use mushrooms machine a
relationship with mr death
maybe three
you recall the specific occasions when
you saw amber heard use mushrooms while
she was in a relationship with mr death
um
the first coachella that we went to
the second coachella that we went to
and
um
maybe at hicksville
with mr deaf at hicksville
yes
around june of 2014 you moved into one
of the penthouses in the eastern
columbia building is that correct
i don't remember which month but i did
move into the penthouses
approximately in 2014
um
approximately
i misheard at the time within a
relationship with mr death correct
yes
[Music]
and it was mr jeff who invited you to
live in one of the penthouses right
they both did
when you say they both did
they both sit you down and invite you to
live in the penthouses
i don't remember how the invitation
happened but it came from both of
them this was the penthouse sister death
owned right
correct
and specifically the one you lived in it
was referred to as penthouse one right
correct
and when you moved in mr duff gave you a
master key to all the penthouses he
owned right
he could have been
one of his
assistance
when you say one of his assistants you
mean mr one of mr daft's assistant
correct
the one either mr depp or one of his
assistants gave you a master key to all
the penthouses that he owned correct
yes
mr duff never charged mr drew for rent
while he lived at penthouse one day
he did not charge
him any right now
did either of you got physical
no
and how was this argument resolved
we talked it out
you recalled another argument was
misheard at holly house is that correct
what was this argument about
[Music]
i think that
we were setting up for thanksgiving
and um
we were looking for
maybe some glasses or some
dishware we had just moved in and
we couldn't find them anywhere
and then um she finally found them in a
place that i thought i had looked and
uh
we started arguing about that
she thought that i wasn't
looking hard enough i think and i
told her that i thought that i looked
there
yeah i think that's what their argument
was about
um was this just a verbal altercation or
did you get physical with each other
um
yeah i believe that we
i believe that i pushed her
how did miss amber heard react to that
she
she either pushed or hit me back
yeah
you know where where she hit you
i think it was on my cheek
did you recall any other
physical
altercations that you've had with miss
amber
no
you recall any specific instances when
you saw amber heard get into a fight
with someone else
no
in the time you've known amber heard
have you ever seen her wear hair
extensions
[Music]
yeah yes
does she have hair extensions in while
she was in a relationship with mr death
i
i i don't know when exactly she
had them throughout
the time of knowing her
i'm going to mark as pennington exhibit
one miss pennington's witness statement
in the uk proceeding which is dated june
16th 2020.
miss pennington first and foremost do
you recognize this document
yes mrs pennington this is this warm
witness statement that you
provided
right i understand i wanted to get to
the bottom and make sure that this was
the one that i signed and saw the date
and
that was the
full document i just finished it yes
this is the document
did you write this witness statement
yourself
yes
i'm sorry i didn't catch that
yes
thank you
did anyone help you write this
um no
did amber heard help you write this
no
did amber heard council help you write
this
no
other than your attorney did you speak
with anyone about the preparation of
this witness statement
no
could please turn to the tenth page of
the document where your signature is
or a signatures
[Music]
is that your signature on the tenth page
of this document ms pennington
that is my e-signature yes
are all the statements in this document
true
to the best of your knowledge and
recollection
yes
you previously testified that you went
on a trip to hicksville with ms heard mr
deb and some other friends is that
correct
yes
you recall when the trip occurred
not off the top of my head
you recall who else went on that trip
yes
[Music]
who else was on that trip
whitney heard
nathan
who was
one of johnny's assistants
[Music]
brittany eustis
kelly
milano
else that you can recall
trying to remember
no i i don't remember anybody else
where were you all staying
at hicksville trailer park
did you personally witness mr dutt
become quote angry and aggressive end
quote toward a friend of yours
yes
relative to where mr death was where
were you when this occurred
um
we were around a campfire
my question is a bit more specific
relative to where mr death was when this
occurred where were you
sitting or standing
i was at the same campfire
how close were you here
six to ten feet
what time of day did this occur
evening
have you consumed any drugs or alcohol
at this time
i think so
what do you recall consuming at that
time
um i don't remember
likely wine
i don't remember specifically
do you smoke any weed no
did you consume any cocaine
no
have you consumed any mushrooms
uh
i believe so
have you consumed any mdma
no
who is the friend that you reference mr
dutt became quote angry and aggressive
towards
um kelly kelly sue
how did you know her
she
was um
married to a work friend of mine
do you have any independent recollection
of how long you had known kelly sue
milano by the time hicksville
occurred
[Music]
more than one year less than two
what did you witness kelly to milano
doing that evening
before mr jet became quote angry and
aggressive
i witnessed her
hang out with
the rest of the group
did you see her consume any alcohol
um
not that i remember
do you see her smoke any weed
no
consume cocaine
no
did you see her consume any mushrooms
um
maybe one
sore i'm i'm i'm genuinely trying to
remember
i saw i saw her eat
some amount i don't know how much
did you see her consume any mdma
no
you testified that mr duff said words to
the effect of quote get off my woman end
quote to your friend is that right
i testified that
did you personally hear mr duff say that
yes
is this the quote angry and aggressive
end quote conduct by mr depp that you
testified to
yes
other than telling kelly sue milano
to quote get off his woman end quote
what did you personally observe mr depp
do that was quote angry and aggressive
unquote
that was
that was what happened then
i think
amber
i think they were kelly and amber were
hugging on a chair
out by the fire
he came out of nowhere said that and
then
i think that amber and johnny went back
to the um
to their trailer
[Music]
other than
hearing mr death
say something to the effect of get off
my woman what did you personally observe
mr that do that was quote angry and
aggressive
that's it
[Music]
did you hear amber say anything to mr
duff
i don't remember her saying anything
did you hear amber heard raise her voice
when speaking to mr duff
no
what if anything do you remember about
amber's reaction to mr depp's behavior
she was trying to comfort him
this evening hicksville did you ever see
amber her consume any drugs or alcohol
i didn't see it
you didn't see ms heard drink any wine
yeah i don't i don't remember a specific
time watching her take a sip of a drink
was she holding a drink
i don't remember
and this evening in pixel did you see mr
dub consume any drugs or alcohol
i didn't see
any specific image of my mind of him
consumed
did you personally witness mr jeff's
quote in a rage
and quote that ms heard described
did i personally witness the rage in the
trailer
yeah
no
did you hear mr depp yelling in the
trailer
no
did you hear miss heard yelling in the
trailer
no
did you personally see that the trailer
was quote trashed as miss heard
described
the next morning
yeah
yes
what specifically did you see in the
trailer
the thing i remember specifically was
the
light fixtures have been knocked off
but you didn't see mr duff knock off the
light fixtures in the trailer is that
correct
i did not see it
so the only thing you know about what
happened in that trailer is what ms
heard told you and your observations of
the light fixtures being knocked off is
that correct
the only thing i know about what
happened in the trailer is what she told
me and what i saw the next morning and
the only thing you saw the next morning
was that the light pictures had been
knocked off is that correct
that was not the only thing i saw it is
the specific thing i saw
what else do you recall about the
trailer
it was in a general disarray
what does that mean
was
trash it was torn apart
what besides the light pictures were
thrown apart
i've already told you specifically i
remember the light fixtures
the rest is a general
disarray
what is a general disarray to you miss
huntington
stuff off the counters
cushions thrown around
things strewn about on the floor
did you see miss heard shortly after she
returned from australia
all right why don't we just stop right
there shall that be a good breaking
point i think okay okay
perfect all right ladies and gentlemen
let's go ahead and break for the evening
again do not discuss
this case with anybody and don't do any
outside research and we'll see you in
the morning at nine o'clock all right
get some sleep okay thank you
so
all right i just have a few items i just
just for the record i want to make sure
exhibit uh plane of one two four eight
from yesterday actually should be
corrected in the record to plaintiff one
two four eight a is that correct
that's correct your honor thank you okay
good all right and so the witnesses
tomorrow are they live remote or do we
need
we have one one live witness tomorrow
the rest are all video depositions
so we don't need a webex link no okay
all right other than that jury
instructions and verdict forms i
received jury instructions from both
parties thank you for that however i
have not received agreed upon jury
instructions as requested
so i'm not sure if that has happened or
not happened
as far as getting an agreed gonna we
have been trying to meet and confirm
that for a week well you know your honor
they're identified and emailed to sami
okay so the ones that you agreed upon
yes okay that's fine so if you could do
the same and just give me which ones you
agree upon
i'd appreciate that um if we can get uh
also by thursday your objections to the
ones that you don't agree upon in
writing to me by thursday morning okay
can we can we get that just so i know
what you're objecting to because i only
have two hours on friday morning from 8
a.m to 10 a.m to to to deal with this
issue so i want to make sure we're all
prepared to get that done at that time
frame okay i understood you're right all
right great anything i just want to make
clear we
we haven't seen what they sent until
they sent today okay that's fine
about this for a week and
i don't i'm not interested in anybody's
finger pointing but i understand but
we'll just go forward from here and if i
can get them thursday morning that would
be fantastic okay
all right
all right have a good evening and we'll
see you in the morning
you